i don't know what you would call
what happened today uh but i'll tell you
i have a lot of people saying
that i predicted it or that
i somehow oh we got this this video
started playing already we got a video
we got to talk about but uh okay let me
start over
i don't know what you'd call it but i
can tell you that yesterday and even
this morning i said i didn't think
anything was going to happen
i showed a clip where people are sharing
this this photo
on twitter of the march for our lives
and i said look look how the left
mobilized
mobilizes
these massive numbers and then i showed
a clip an image
from the the rally earlier today
and i said the numbers are nowhere near
comparable you know so trump supporters
certainly have come out but i don't
think
you know we'll see anything crazy and
boy was i wrong
a group of trump supporters made their
way
inside the capitol building windows got
smashed out they breached it
tear gas was fired in the rotunda this
is some of the craziest
the craziest things i've ever seen i
know a lot of people are trying to
compare this
to when brett kavanaugh was being
confirmed and the protesters with the
atrium of the senate building this is
not comparable this is an electoral
college vote count and some dude with
with viking horns
took the vice president's seat in the
senate
and like yelled and some some guy was
stealing the podium this was really
really crazy stuff but worst
of all of it a woman has been killed
and i watched this video i don't know if
you've seen it but there is a door
to the uh to the main chamber of i think
it was the
congressional main chamber the house and
there's a barricade put in front of it
and there's a bunch of capital uh
security with their guns trained in the
door
one of those is what we believe to have
happened shot
through the door blindly at a bunch of
individuals and there was a woman who
was not at the door but just standing
behind some people and she took the shot
to the neck
and you could see it man uh if you watch
the video if you have experience with
combat
i think most people realized it because
the moment i saw that i said
she's gone and they reported as critical
condition but i was like nah she's gone
and then it was a few hours later they
announced officially that she passed
away so this is some of the this is
intense stuff man
they just shot through that door and now
she's dead now we're seeing cnn's
calling it insurrection
they said this is an insurrection trump
encouraged it trump then tweeted
something out that i wouldn't
necessarily say was direct support but
boy did it feel kind of like it
when he was like remember this day go
home and be peaceful the election was
stolen i was just like dude
i don't know what you call it man and i
don't know what what many of these
people expect because right now you got
i think it's cory bush i'm not sure
if i don't want to drag the wrong person
but they're calling for the expulsion
of republicans who are supporting trump
rand paul has now said
that they're going to go in there will
be no objections joe biden is going to
be certified especially after this so
i don't want to i don't want to just go
through everything before i even get
started we got a bunch of really great
people here
uh of course we have the usual crew we
got luke rodkowski yup
today was a crazy day it's only going to
get crazier from here i was breaking it
all down
on twitter.com luke we are change i got
there's crazy
developments i mean the cpac's match lap
just came out
and said quote i understand there's a 16
year old woman who was shot
16. now he goes on now maybe she was
doing terrible things and deserved to be
shot we're in the party that talks about
law and order and respecting cops he
said that on fox news
16 year old and he said according to him
the woman that was shot and killed the
unarmed woman that was shot and killed
was a 16 year old girl
so that's the breaking news coming in
now that i just had to get into they
found
this at the moment more than one and
they and they detonated them
so uh ian's hanging out yeah yeah um
elijah shafer apparently was posting
evidence that there's
antifa there posing as trump supporters
hard to prove hard to prove
i saw the picture though and it was
definitely no the the i well i don't
know what you saw but i do know that
there's some stuff going around that is
not true
it was corey bush by the way who wants
to expel yep
expel a bunch of uh there's an image
going around that says philly antifa
and it's a picture of some guys that
video is not of
it's from philly antifa and people think
it shows all the guys who are there rant
but it's not true okay
but uh jack murphy's here what's up
everybody good to see you tim good to be
back hello
hi jeffy ian how are you great to see
you lilia everybody crazy day in dc i
was there
for a good part of it i saw the speech
pretty much front row center
i saw people as far as i could see all
the way back from the ellipse all the
way through the park across constitution
up the hill towards washington monument
there was just a tremendous amount of
people there spirits were very high
energy was high
positive at first and then afterwards it
started to get a little bit weird man i
saw some things i hadn't seen in dc
how many people you think were there in
total you know i'm not i'm not really
great at that but uh my guess would be a
couple hundred thousand
really yeah i mean 400 000. i mean the
whole ellipse was completely filled wow
and then the streets and then the whole
section back behind it but
awesome compare this to some of the left
left-wing protest riots you've been to
you think a hundred thousand uh i think
it was i think i think it was
more uh in mass than i had seen
throughout the summer yeah wow i mean
there was a lot of people at those
protests this summer but this was just
everywhere and then all the way down
pennsylvania avenue and constitution and
up to the capitol
but uh it's good to be back bigger than
december bigger than december
wow uh about the same yeah it was a lot
of people it was a lot so
last month the left was saying barely
mustering a hundred thousand
and the right was saying two hundred
thousand so i'm like all right well
somewhere in the middle right
the left is criticizing him saying it
was a million you know maga march and
only a hundred thousand showed up
right all right 100 000. yeah a million
men didn't come to the million man march
either right
just fyi my friends if you have not
already smash the like button subscribe
to the notification bell
we got we got so much to go through and
there's a lot of philosophical
discussions that are going to happen
right now
and uh the first thing i want to do is
we got to talk about this young woman
and we got to talk about you know
trump's been suspended there's just
there's just so much going on we'll just
try to get through it
but this is the most important story
this is from wusa9
woman shot inside u.s u.s capitol
building during riot dies from injuries
it is not known yet what exactly led to
the shooting a photo shows law
enforcement with guns drawn inside the
lockdown house chamber
they say dc's mayor muriel bowser and
police chief robert conte iii also
confirmed
that a person was shot inside the
capitol building but did not release
much more details
in the news conference at 5 p.m the
behavior we are witnessing is shameful
unpatriotic and above all it is unlawful
anyone who engages in his activities
continues to engage in this
in these activities will be held
accountable said bowser
a lockdown was in place wednesday
afternoon for the u.s capitol building
uh and it has been lifted according to
officials but there's still a curfew
right my understanding is there
it started at 6 00 p.m earliest one i
can remember yeah curfew earliest
6 p.m curfew this is not on a weekday
yeah
they say u.s park police dc police and
national guard troops
have worked to move trump supporters and
rioters gathered gathered at the steps
of the us capitol building
to create a safety perimeter tear gas
and percussion grenades
have been deployed by police around the
u.s capitol to move back rioters
it is not known yet what exactly led to
the woman being shot but a photo from
cbs news's zak hudak
shows law enforcement with guns drawn
inside the house chamber
around 2 46 p.m after rioters broke into
the u.s capitol building
u.s capitol police ordered the capitol
lockdown around 2 30 p.m on wednesday
and evacuations of two capital campus
buildings the library of congress james
madison memorial building
and the cannon house office building as
protests raged at the capitol complex
shortly after president trump addressed
his voters vowing never to concede
the election in a speech on the ellipse
large crowds of pro-trump protesters
marched to the u.s capitol
and squared off with capitol police
protesters broke through several
uh barriers placed at the steps of the
capitol while the certification of
electoral college votes began inside
and then as you as many of you probably
already know if you don't they suspended
they recessed the joint session of
congress
joe manchin said that these thugs will
not stop us from counting
the the votes and that they're planning
on going back in as soon as the
buildings are secure
i don't there's there's blood on the
ground there's a woman who died
and they're going to go back in and
they're going to finish in many places
than one there's blood and my news team
actually sent me the video of the
shooting and before the shooting
and it looks like people just milling
around of course you don't see who
shot you don't see it in the exact frame
with this
allegedly now we're getting information
16 year old girl that was there
but you hear the shot and it's extremely
graphic and you see the life literally
leave her eyes so
it's extremely intense and right now on
twitter there's many hashtags that are
trending one of them is white privilege
and a lot of people are saying look how
favorable these protesters were treated
right now protesters are actually
engaged with uh conflicts with the
police there and
a lot of left lane leaning kind of
thinkers in the mainstream media are
saying look these protesters were
treated favorably
but we have an unarmed 16 year old girl
shot and killed today that's something
that's that's something incredibly
important
something that needs to be investigated
something that there needs to be justice
behind it just like any
death that leads to a police officer
shooting something or doing something
that that
leads to an end of a life which is
absolutely insane
she was in the front by the way no she
wasn't she was standing like right at
the door
and then she got hit and got knocked
back onto the ground i didn't see that
that's a video on twitter i'm really
looking for it right now i'm going to
retweet it
the video i saw there's there's like one
guy
wearing a poofy jacket in the front and
one guy is like his hands up and then he
backs up against the wall
then someone walks in front of the
camera and the woman is further back
okay
all of twitter about to become a cab
you've been feeling it over the last few
days anyway
sentiment has definitely been turning
it's almost like an instantaneous
network
shift where the whole right network just
was like all of a sudden
blue blue lives whatever yeah seriously
whatever
i push back on that on my twitter i mean
i i support the police in dc they
usually do a tremendous job under very
very difficult
they're difficult did you see the video
of what happened today i did but i don't
have any other information and i also
has anybody matched up a shot of the
police from the outside and the the
people on the inside
like a picture yeah yeah i think i think
we've seen pictures of guns drawn
inside the chamber there's video of the
people inside the doors
there's video of the other people
pulling the trigger but no
nobody shot into the chamber i
understand that
the they shot from inside the chamber no
one knows all
the video is you saw the video people
are milling about and then you hear the
shot right but where was that door
leading
those are my questions where's that door
that they're like one thing that's all
in the main chamber where the guys have
their guns
at the door there wasn't a rush there
wasn't a fight there wasn't a conflict
it's literally people milling about like
they were even in an elevator
so so that's another thing to really
well the window was broken yeah yeah
yeah
and then they barricaded the door it
looked like there was a puzzle i want to
say too there's no confirmation yet that
she was 16.
yeah i've seen this is according to the
cpac that just released this information
and there are some
high profile blue check individuals
saying a 16 year old girl died but
i think i saw jack basobic maybe
somebody else comparing the images from
the
the officers with the guns drawn to the
scene where people where the woman was
shot and like pointing out
differences in the door and that it
wasn't the same door really and then it
might have been somewhere else i i can't
confirm that it's just something i saw
in the passing game
yeah because some windows looked the
same yeah i could be wrong though you
know whenever it comes to big breaking
stories like this
uh details come out usually get
corrected later on
and then people i mean it always happens
but then people might say like but hold
on
on the day of they reported this that
and this and then it changes like well
yeah
in this case though no no relevant
detail is going to change except for the
fact that
the story will be maga fascist storm the
capital
girl gets killed attack police
insurrection
etc etc well watching cnn before this
broadcast they were trying to kind of
obfuscate that and make it not a big
deal
they were more they were more talking
about look the members of congress were
terrified and they were focusing in on
that and then they kind of mentioned in
passing there was also a protester shot
and killed
in other news and other news look how
and then it was just
extremely eye-opening to see cnn the
network that just a few weeks ago
was telling you on national television
that protests are not supposed to be
peaceful
literally lose their ish today talking
about insurgencies
terrorists and this extremely uh warfare
kind of language trying to deem what
they saw today as the worst possible
thing in the world now again it wasn't
nice it wasn't good
obviously there was a lot of turmoil
obviously there was a lot of chaos
there's a lot of confusion we're still
finding out exactly what happened about
this event
but this is the same network again
during the summer when similar events
were happening
all throughout the country they were
supporting it and cheering it on you
so yeah let me show you let's hope this
photo real quick this is from i just
pulled up on google images from today
and it says members of i believe is
members of congress being given
gas masks there are these like plastic
bags you put over your head with a
filtration system
i think one of the craziest things i
have ever heard in my life
tear gas fired in the rotunda man i
mentioned mustard gas yesterday i was
kind of half joking but it can get
super extreme when chaos strikes well
listen listen
when you fire tear gas indoors people
die
it displaces oxygen i have seen people
catches on fire
when you're jammed together in a crowd
you're basically indoors like in waco
well no in crowds the air clears quickly
people disperse if you can disperse if
you can't though it's a different story
sure but if you've ever been locked
shoulder to shoulder pressed and you
can't move you're just being moved with
the clutch so when i was in town
when i was in turkey during the gezi
park protests
there is uh istiklao which is this big
corridor of uh shopping markets
like it's it's a big shopping street
it's amazing really
and this is in this this is in uh uh
istanbul and when they start firing tear
gas like crazy
you can't go anywhere you're you're
you're in this corridor and you're
trying to run
out and the gas doesn't dissipate
because the buildings are all by your
side so that i get but when you're
inside a building you know what we ended
up seeing
people were running into parking garages
and
then then you're you're sealed in
perfectly when the tear gas went in
people just started dropping to the
ground
because they're not breathing air
anymore you're breathing in tear gas you
can't breathe
once it gets in your lungs your lungs
constrict you struggle and hit the
ground
and then people started running in with
masks and pulling out bodies of
unconscious people
when they said they tear gas the rotunda
i was just like dude
people are gonna die nah nobody i don't
think anybody died
from that we did see some people get
carried out but
somebody died from taking a bullet now
now here's the thing luke is wearing a
very interesting t-shirt
well i've been i've been selling this
t-shirt for about over a year now i've
been i've been talking about
this for i think i can't even i can't
even
understand how long i've been talking
about this but i've been talking about
this hyper
partisan this hyper this sensationalism
bull crap that people call news that
again is just weaponized information
meant so people fight each other
and now we're here at this crescendo and
i think this is only the beginning of a
lot of
more horrible things to come in my
opinion definitely well
so the shirt luke is wearing is that
it's the guy poking meme
and he says come on do a civil war and
it's the donkey and the elephant
and the guy is abc fox cbs cnn the
reason why this is important let me
let me show you this uh from cnn trump
caused this insurrection and every
republican must condemn it
they're calling it an insurrection on uh
on tv
i hate when this happens well the former
president george w bush also
written just just released a very strong
statement calling this an insurrection
george w bush it's an insurrection
that's what cnn has said
uh fox news is calling it a protest
after they cleared out the capital
people were still
pushing they were still fighting tear
gas was still being deployed
and when i see cnn going on tv
and attacking just blanket blanket
attacks i'm like they really don't get
it
right they're absolutely trying their
hardest to inflame
tensions they don't care that what they
do
makes everything worse and you the best
part is you know i love the most
i have these people who tweeted me
saying like you you helped cause this
tim
like your videos your content and i'm
like you mean every single video where
i've said violence doesn't work and it's
bad for everybody who does it
this is what's amazing that we can have
a show like this where repeatedly say
violence doesn't work non-violent civil
disobedience is one of the most
effective things because we're in
fifth generational warfare maybe you can
talk about violent revolution in the
1700s
but when it comes to today's day and age
it's all about perception and fifth
generational warfare
the problem is cnn what did what did who
was it was it cuomo
was it cuomo who was like and who says
protests need to be peaceful
bruce cuomo said who said protests need
to be peaceful and that gave birth to
ramen guy
you guys remember ramen guy right and
he's eating the ramen he goes it's right
there in the first amendment mr cuomo
yes it is right yeah he's got to look it
up now what are they saying
oh it's insurrection we knew these
trumpers would do it
well i'll tell you man i have no idea
what these people are thinking because
they're not going to win anything this
is going to be
this is going to be a big crackdown from
the security statement in may they
burned down the guard
tower in the white house again we
shouldn't really be comparing the two
but we should
note that that events are being
manipulated
information is being hidden from you
it's being editorialized
to push an agenda and that agenda is for
you guys to fight each other speaking of
the video of the girl
standing up on the door you retweeted it
yeah it was from she's on the door
she's like standing like this on the
door yeah she's right on the door and
she gets hit and knocked back it got
removed from twitter
oh they were interesting yeah i'm
looking at it right now i can see it in
my feed and then when i go to the i just
retweeted it and it was removed right
all right so here's the thing this is
why it's not the same this is why may is
not the same this is why today was a
mistake but i want to say first off that
i understand i understand why people are
upset i understand why they want to rage
i understand why they feel like
i i understand why black lives matter
wants to raise totally i understand why
they feel like this may be the last
chance to have a republic if this is the
end if they have it you know
clean sweep of the legislature and the
presidency it's going to be gone the
rest of the country is going to be gone
i understand
why people would feel upset the
difference is
is that the maga insurrection the maga
revolution the maga network
is not in alignment with the
corporations it's not in alignment with
the media and so
when black lives matter and antifa are
so black lives matter and antifa they
can go do this exact kind of thing
and get a favorable reaction to their
tribe and still maintain their moral
victory within their tribe
we try to do it and it's instantly going
to get shot down we have no media
backing we've got no actual narrative
backing on this
and it's counterproductive and it's
damaging to these people these people
that ran into the capital
prison prison this dude was running
around
with like the the stand you know like
the day or smiling at the camera and i
was like bro you're going to
prison for a long time like prison and
it was just today an hour ago
at the speech trump goes and you know
what we made it 10
years to mess with any of our federal
monuments or buildings or whatever the
case so like 10 years dude you're going
to prison 10 years yup
10 years and so it's not going to work
we have to have
the right has to have a different
strategy than the left and the left
strategy means that the tactics they can
use are things like
have riots burn down buildings
antagonize the police
do all these things because they get
echoed in support from the corporations
maga cannot do it because the net result
is a negative it's not a positive
nothing was gained
today only things were lost today and
the people who lost that girl lost her
life
those people are going to lose their
freedom they're going to go to prison
and we are all going to lose liberty
come this new administration when they
use this as the new
impetus for the double down triple extra
hard patriot act
that's coming right up your ass well
chuck schumer is comparing what happened
today to pearl harbor
so yes we're going to have a lot of
politicians
uh milking this cow until until
it has come home until the roosters come
home i think it's good and i just i just
want to finish this thought i've been
catching a lot of creep on twitter today
because i've been recommending that
people
women and children and non-combatants
get out of dc tonight because it's not
safe
i've been recommending that people stay
out of trouble and stay out of harm's
way and not commit violence and not
commit crimes
why because it's not the right tactic
today all it's going to do is do harm
to you there has to be other strategies
we're working on them i'm personally
working on them we have networks of
people working on it
but we can't mimic what the other side
is doing because they have a completely
different
background high ground or not they just
have the corporations in the media and
it all works together here's an analogy
imagine you control the high ground so
your strategy is to aim
down and fire yeah and imagine if then
the trump supporters all
see them up on top of the hill pointing
their guns down and go we should point
our guns down too
and they all or if they're
but the people on the bottom can't use
throwing rocks as a tactic because they
can't get the rocks up there
that's the point like they're a little
different the antifa and the leftists
like like jack said have corporations on
their side trump supporters don't it's
not a tactic you can use
gravity yeah well we watched black lives
matter get record support after george
floyd and then they
lit it on fire when they rioted and i've
made so many videos saying this
proves this should be the proof to
everybody violence
does not work again we can talk about
the boston tea party we can talk about
the 1700s
but we are in the information age fifth
generational warfare is about
manipulation tactics and propaganda
and that means they'll find a picture of
you wiping your butt and be like look
what he's doing and they'll post it
everywhere act like it's the end of the
world
but antifa can throw a brick at
someone's face and they're gonna be like
it's a peaceful protest
in fourth or fifth generation war there
are there are additional layers to the
combat space that there was before
besides being just physical there's
mental and moral
and in our environment the moral plane
is one of the most
important ones to win it's not about a
moral victory and that's something that
you get even though you lost
it's not about keeping the moral high
ground about taking some sort of
highfalutin you know and you know your
integrity in some some regard
it's about just winning the moral war as
in having the support
of the people as in having the people on
your side
as in leading people it's not and not
pushing people away
storming the capital is going to push
away people who you need the support of
what this is i think they i think they
uh uh
well i'll i'll stop where i was gonna
say i'm gonna say this the cops are on
video
opening up the barricades i saw that i
said and a lot of people are saying
no no no that was different that was
different that wasn't the same moment as
when they were
pushing on the cops and shaking the
barricades and pulling them down but it
was a moment where the police opened up
the barricades and then you hear
people yelling they're just letting them
into the capitol they're
opening up the capitol building to these
people like they're they're at the
capitol building when they did this
there's there's a video a photo going
around of cbp
and like locking down and like they're
like we're we are we are
sending out cbp officers to guard the
capital while these protests and riots
are going on
so a lot of people are asking why is it
that this time when we knew
trump was saying come on down it'll be
wild
we knew that the the media kept saying
over and over again trump is instigating
violence and i left i was like
trump said come bro doesn't say do
anything you're calling it instigating
and then the police weren't there with
enough force or presence to do anything
to stop this
let alone them opening up the barricades
it's i mean it's better
than them down the crowd no no no no
listen
when when when the when the black lives
matter people were there they had
uh police riot police with shields
lining the streets this time
they had a couple of cops with batons
why was that why do you think they let
them in
no idea i don't know there's a number of
different access points to the capitol
grounds that was just one of them there
were people scaling walls there was
another time i saw them fighting for the
gates i mean
i i have no idea what happened there i'm
gonna i'm gonna try to find also another
thing that i think really people need to
kind of think about here
why are people surprised when the
establishment the mainstream media the
corporations politicians codified and
normalized
violence as a way to get political power
just a few weeks ago
this is something that's becoming the
new norm we've been calling it out no
matter who does it
and and people are of course making
arguments saying if they did it we could
do it too and again that's a that's
that's not a good logic
it's not new norm it's the old norm it's
the norm norm
it's the norm norm i mean has it hasn't
been this prevalent
uh as of as of late i mean we get to
make historical historical stories
but as of late i think that's that's
something that's important just a few
weeks ago
like well specifically when we were
talking about you know black lives
matter
let's let's bring them up here in a
specific context they got billions of
dollars they got institutional support
they had major corporations major
politicians supporting them
after committing violent acts
we'll talk about the differences here
literally paid so the first thing is
these are trump supporters who who shut
down and breached the electoral college
vote count for the presidency it's
serious yeah but it was one time and it
was i think 300 people they estimated
black lives matter was what three weeks
of nationwide riots
over 2 billion dollars in damage and 30
people dead or something
30 plus it was yeah 30 plus people died
in the riots not all from rioters but in
rising
under reported and confiscated even by
the reporting by michael
tracy who went out there and covered
that the damage was far bigger than we
even knew about it
and then how much money did black lives
matter bring in it was it wasn't
billions 10 billion they were given
money what lesson does that teach the
average person out there who's paying
attention what lesson does that kind of
show
what works to the average destroying
private property is okay but if you mess
with government property
it's not okay right it should be it
should be the other way around exactly
exactly yeah that's it well and then and
you know you said that that the uh the
left
lit the goodwill on fire that they
gained through the
the protests earlier i i think that
that's not entirely true
as i was downtown i noted i every time i
looked up
each building had a giant black lives
matter banner on it the churches have
them covering
it you know the uh it's it's everywhere
they it's like they
they they won they won in dc that's for
sure black lives matter has not
extinguished any of its support
it has not burned through uh that that
capital that it earned
aside from the 10 billion dollars and if
you can't take any lesson at all it's
like you do that but that's the problem
they were baited we were baited into
behaving like antifa and black lives
matter we cannot
it is counterproductive to our strategy
let me back this up
correct yes i think you're right that
people do generally support black lives
matter
but i have a graph here that i want
people to see which i've shown before
from civics
black lives matter registered voters do
you support or oppose the black lives
matter movement
right after the george floyd incident
net support for black
i'm sorry right before george floyd lost
his life net support for black lives
matter was at 18
so that means like above the the the
margin like above 50 percent
when the when the protests spiked 24
net support then the riot started before
remember before george floyd black lives
matters enjoyed 18
the riots hit and it dropped from 24 all
the way down
to 8 where it currently sits right now
eight percent
they had 18 they lost 10 percent of
their net support in this country by
rioting
and it has not come back so they do
enjoy
general support on average in this
country but it was a point where even
conservatives were like i understand
this george floyd thing was really bad
then they went and burned down mom and
pop shops yeah it's not like the mogan
network went into this scene at the
capitol building with
credit goodwill credit in the bank
exactly they already went in negative
owing money
on the run from the debtor the creditor
is trying to chase him down
and then they go and then they they just
chop their face off man
but you know so that that i replayed her
you put that down with cops
but they're saying that uh uh one of
these guys like a really well-known q
conspiracy guy like the viking guy has
been seen at events holding up signs for
q
some people are trying to claim these
black lives matter and well he may have
been at an event but they cropped out
there's a photo i see going around and
you can't see what the sign says it's
cropped out
you sent me and it yes it said i think
it pretty much says that literally it
says q sent me oh yeah
that's the sign that he has there
there's a there's a meme of him now
and it has that famous picture and it
says when you ordered the village people
from wish
and then it's a picture of him and all
the other people standing in the
background there
but again a lot of disinformation a lot
of people just manipulating facts
editorializing so they could push a
certain agenda
and when we just stop looking at these
agendas we see a very
uh very very bad picture of more
fuel on the fire and that's exactly
what's happening with all the reporting
supposedly
that's going on today with again just
trying to get as much disinformation
trying to get as much propaganda trying
to brainwash people to make you
understand
that guy's going to hurt you you need to
fight him at all costs and now we're
here at this stage and we're not going
to be going away anytime soon
because the algorithms that incentivize
it the mainstream media that spews it
the politicians who allow it they're the
ones who are still sadly
at the helms and are going to be
expanding it and pushing this to a level
that
is it's going to become more and more
unlivable more and more
apparent whatever the conditions were
that launched trump into presidency in
2016
are today now and going to get much
worse
than they were in 2015. it's going to be
worse than the last term of the obama
presidency
they've got more money they're better
established they've taken over more
institutions
it's more in our schools it's more in
our kids our kids our kids are
just reciting things without even
understanding it so if you didn't like
the way things were before
i have a feeling you're not going to
like them very much in the night ladies
and gentlemen i have an important update
i just got a notification uh google has
disabled chat on this stream
what's that for obvious reasons get out
of town
chat has been disabled so uh no more
chat for people who are watching but
they're allowing the stream to continue
because i guess
i guess because our conversation is is
calm and reasonable and you know we're
very much very anti-violent
chad's saying we're not even making any
allegations we're not telling you what
other people are saying chad has been
disabled for things that people are
saying they can't control and we can't
moderate
wow so they're shutting it down well
okay welcome to
whatever is coming next i got no idea
we're watching it in action but i i just
got contacted by google right now that
uh we
we noticed chat wasn't working okay
and uh yeah so we're making argument
arguments against radicalization no no
it's not on us the stream's okay
yeah the checking gets yeah but you
still you still get punished because
again people come to engage people talk
to people want to have those
conversations and they can't right now i
love to read the show this is
well what what better segue than to uh
talk about what's going on with with
with trump and twitter and let me let me
tell you right now
so uh what i'm what i'm being told is
that
uh for those that are just tuning in
chat has been disabled because
people in comments are inciting violence
calling for more and things like that
and there's just too many comments i
mean we've got about a hundred thousand
people who are who are live right now
it's it's
it's big a lot's going on so i'll say
this
um let me ask you guys your opinions
because i think
it's a tough call when you have tons of
people encouraging and inciting
especially a time when things are so
precarious
and you know google is basically saying
keep doing the stream we're not we're
not it's not on you guys but we can't
control this
how do you guys feel about this
disabling whenever you stop
conversations from happening you feel
bad conversations
what's the saying if you want to defeat
a bad idea you defeat it with good ideas
but by censoring it you make it fester
in the dark
darkest nastiest ugliest elements of the
internet that do exist and will continue
to exist and will even persist even more
once you censor that conversation for
taking place yes yes but there's a
difference between
saying bad opinions and inciting
violence well if someone's docking
doxxing someone or or saying threatening
to do that force well obviously those
individuals should be
obviously dealt with with the first
amendment and the law like we have
on the books right now of course that's
something that that has been
followed right right right and then
that's nothing different i understand
i'm just saying in this capacity i am
100
against inciting violence yeah and i
always exactly i always say this
free speech stops we start directing
people to commit crimes and hurt others
youtube is saying right now that too
many people in the chat are saying that
as a moderator from mines i think that
they did the right thing
because it's illegal to incite violence
and if they leave the incitement of
violence on their platform
they become liable well deal with those
individuals though don't take down a
whole conversation
with the live chat you're right but we
have a hundred thousand people so what
they'll do is they'll go on the comments
later and they'll
remove any violence incitements and
they'll strike those accounts but it was
just too much
at once for them to for any moderator or
ai probably even to control
i'll tell you guys what it's really
really simple um who wants to be the
official twitter
uh chat question receiver i can do it
uh i'll do it everybody actually yeah
right now
at sauerkraut twitter you can follow
that's our patch lids and tweet at
questions
oh jack murphy live at jack murphy live
there you go at jack murphy live
luke we are change luke we are changed
feel free to ask me anything and then
we'll just not me because i don't check
notifications
for sure no kidding well we can use
we'll use twitter and
and uh in that capacity twitter is look
if you break twitter's rules
of course i'm one of the you know uh
most free speech people when it comes to
social media platforms but
so that's the best we can do for now so
you guys check your twitter feeds we can
do questions that way later on in the
show and we can
have the chat you guys can tweet at us i
already i already tweeted out no chat
for you
um because we don't have chat anymore
you may have noticed so if you guys want
to send me any
questions you have or whatever on there
that would be good tower patch lids at
sourpatchlids on twitter
oh we just invited we just invited
the tim cast irl chat into my mentions
got speed jack as well they're good
people i welcome them
yeah so uh well here's the here's the
here's the news from cnbc
twitter locks trump's account following
video addressing washington rioters
twitter said on wednesday that would
lock the account of the president for 12
hours after he posted tweets continuing
to make false claims about the election
facebook youtube and twitter on
wednesday removed a video by president
donald trump
addressing washington rioters meanwhile
calls our mounting for twitter and
facebook to suspend
trump's accounts so i don't i don't know
if they have the uh
i don't think they're going to show what
trump said uh so i guess
i can we can only sort of allude to it
it's been banned from everywhere which
is really dangerous in my opinion just
that one tweet that got taken down in
history
two tweets and then he's he's he's
banned from using the account for for 12
hours i watched the video and in the
video he says
okay guys go home he's urging his
supporters to
to leave the capitol so yeah those are
important videos that
i think you know maybe some people
should see i don't think censoring it
is going to i think that's a bad idea
but um one of the tweets that got
removed was him saying or it was a post
on facebook as well
he said you know this is what happens
when you there's a landslide and it's
stolen
never you go home and in peace never
forget this day yeah it says
when a sacred landslide election victory
is so unceremoniously and viciously
stripped away from great patriots who
have been
badly and unfairly treated for so long
my gosh ceremony
what was what was how was that even a
landslide he's just such a blowhard
well i don't like that guy man and i
don't like the way he governs
so they removed it that was that was
wrong i don't know i wouldn't remove
that
what they have done is there's a fire
going on right now and it's
bigger and more dangerous than we've
ever seen to the point where youtube has
literally disabled our comments
and they they come out and they say guys
we're gonna help put this fire out and
they light their flamethrowers and they
spray fire
all over everything put out fire with
fire and they tell you they're making it
i mean they're making it worse but they
tell you they're putting the fire out
while they spray it's firemen coming out
like a night in fahrenheit for
451 with flamethrowers saying we're the
firemen
why didn't they do the same to cnn
that's spewing hyperbolic nonsense are
they going to do the same to the
mainstream media because it's only fair
if they do it to them now
and then again we have to look here cnn
openly
told people protests are not supposed to
be peaceful they're the ones that were
inciting
violence not so long ago and i mean
we're here actually having a
conversation
trying to break down what's happening
and why it's happening and i think
understanding a problem leads us towards
fixing it
but censoring conversation censoring
dialogue centering speech
it's only going to create a worser
problem in my opinion that's what i
personally think
yeah absolutely there is a value to
censoring well okay the word sensor just
means to be the gatekeeper so you can
censor something and allow it to exist
and censor something and take it down
it's your choice you are the censor
look you're just taking information
that's the sense pros and cons yes
there there's there's a benefit to
censorship it's just we believe in
liberty
and i think if you if you go by the the
root definition of the word
removing someone who has an opinion
which would incite violence would be
censorship to a certain degree and we
accept these limits and if it's not
illegal then we accept it
if it's illegal then we have to censor
it we're supposed to anyway
on the margin somehow banning trump from
his twitter at this point in time
is going to increase agitation among the
people who are
already agitated yeah do you think that
that was the intended uh
consequence or uh accidental byproduct
of the
i think it's accidental yeah i think
these people are really really really
dumb
yeah there's it's it's it's what i refer
to as a chinese finger trap problem
everyone's you've seen those little toys
you put your fingers in your pole and it
gets tighter the harder you pull and
that's what they're doing
they don't realize that a lot of the
anger we're seeing is because
of this and so at one of the worst
possible moments they said let's really
remind
each and every one of these people who
is losing their mind how much we hate
them
yeah that's that's the message being
sent out and it's terrifying
this is the wrong move for everybody and
that's what really freaks me out when
cnn on the tv
i cannot believe what i was hearing they
said it's insurrection in dc and all the
stuff and i'm like you guys
are throwing kerosene into the fire pit
they don't care they don't care they
know that they can continue to just keep
doing this to make
things worse if it bleeds it leads they
say in media
indeed but you know from their
perspective it does feel like an
insurgency to them
an insurrection an interaction it feels
like it to them that's
i think that they truly believe it and
that when they say that that is an
honest statement in congruency with
their inner self like that's
what they feel how they see the world
and they feel like they're telling the
truth and i believe
to the extent it's possible that that's
an honest statement
coming from them but how would that be
how do you think they would see that as
an insurrection
because it feels like it because they
think trump is a fascist because they
think that we're all
fascists and because they think that
there was people going to take over the
capital with armed weapons or burn it
down
disrupt constitutional processes they
look guys
they they disrupted the moment
that the left has been just begging for
and
dying for ever since november of 2015.
this this was the moment and and it was
disrupted so of course it feels like an
instruction to them
of course it feels like it it quite
literally was
a disruption of a constitutional process
that was going to lead to their
president that they wanted to happen how
else would you view it if you were them
well that's sorry guys
that shows that cnn doesn't view half of
this country
as legitimate i thought we were beyond
talking about that no it wasn't that
that's that's taken but that's but i
think you're right and i think it's
exactly
my point yeah you know our points are uh
uh the same
thing right they did storm the capitol
on the throne they have a right
to feel that like but when you look at
the actual kind of events it's
disorganized it's chaos there wasn't
any kind of unified plan or action by
the vice president or the president
you have the vice president coming out
you have the president come in
and saying legitimately hey guys it's
important that we bring everyone back
home
uh you know protect the police officers
back the blue that's literally the
messaging
happening in there nothing was really it
doesn't seem like it from my own
personal experiences like nothing was
really planned and organized here
it just seems it seems like it it's it's
something that happened from the utter
chaos that has been building and spewing
and they've been trying to keep under
and the more they try to keep it under
the more it kind of popped all right let
me tell you continue to pop up with
these kind of activities
here is someone that deserves to blame
sydney powell
that cracking the cracking [ __ ] lynnwood
lynnwood
these people and q these people on these
networks and that thing
they pump people full of false hope they
riled people up and they promised them
that something was coming but it's just
been getting crazier and crazier and
crazy i mean come on lynnwood tweeting
that mike pence needs to be
removed and charged with treason yeah he
may be having a psychotic breakdown
20 000 retweets not a ratio people were
pushing this and supporting this
well yeah why didn't they of all the
tweets that they should have been
censoring it should have been those
they should have censored him and been
like go talk to your therapist right
like people in an
obvious mental breakdown they should
they should block those people but i
but seriously i don't think so you don't
you i don't think he should have been
banned i think
i think i'm being tongue-in-cheek this
is not my official courtroom position on
that matter
we're just talking a little ish on that
right so but but it's an important point
to bring up lynn wood was saying crazy
stuff and
it should be a reminder to everybody
like don't listen
you know what i mean like this is why
this guy is not trustworthy
and i'm seeing tons of trump supporters
being like dude this guy's losing
it what happened you know he's having a
break or something but you know even
from people that i thought were savvy
whatever i get these messages trust the
plan well you don't know what's going to
happen in georgia and just wait till the
six and oh my god this is gonna happen
these people were waiting for something
and you know what trump was there i
think that they thought
maybe that trump was going to make this
speech on the ellipse
was going to lay it all out finally was
the finally the truth
i know but the trust the plan moment was
this was supposed to be their climax i
think
yeah and then they were let down this is
the first comment that i got
from people coming in and asking
questions and comments
and one of them says what are people
supposed to do when they lose their
voice and the courts are
scared or unwilling to see or hear the
problem that's the point of
non-violent total civil disobedience
totally like i mentioned the other day
what would have happened if a bunch of
trump supporters were just
you know standing in the roads and
people couldn't get through non-violent
civil disobedience
and create a new network create a new
concept
to rely on like a new constitution it's
fifth generational warfare
okay not warfare in the sense of people
fighting it's in it's in the battle for
the mind it's the battle for resources
and for for ideology
and that means you win when you are
moral when you are principled
when you uh when you were persuasive tim
uh i've been talking about these issues
for better part of two years now a lot
of my podcasts with john rob we talk
about fourth generation warfare
inside the liminal order we study fourth
generation warfare how it impacts us how
we can use it
uh in the world to manifest more of our
values but tim i got
to ask you a personal question uh of all
the times i've been on this show like 10
times by now
i've never heard you use these phrases
fifth generation
did you have a guest on recently that
where you had like an in-depth
conversation about it no
no no no no we were privately talking
about it for weeks
yeah i've been i've been posting about
generational warfare for a year or two
yeah so uh i actually but you're
absolutely i mean you're absolutely
right i mean you're
speaking the same exact language and
it's not it it's a completely different
battle space like trying to storm the
capital
is makes no sense it has no place
in a war that's fought on a moral and
mental dimension think about this think
about
what do you do inside the capital like
what did what did anyone think would
happen
you go in and you have no institutional
power or control
or confidence one thing i've been saying
a whole lot
the purpose of fifth generational
warfare which more has to do with media
and propaganda
is building confidence in your system
this is why i've been saying that
linwood is one of the most destructive
and dangerous things for trump and his
supporters
because he's stripping trump of
legitimacy and you know what
trump didn't come out and disavow or
shut it down and trump supporters didn't
either and that's how they lost
legitimacy
and every trump supporter i know
in my network disavowed and shot down
linwood
i'm not saying every single trump's
reporter was like i'll keep my mouth
shut no no it was that there were many
trump supporters
who were retweeting and propping it up
and there were and i'm not
not the prominent ones not a lot of uh
you know
higher profile personalities but i would
tweet something like you know uh
it's it's about time a loved one took
linwood's phone away and i get people
saying like you should really be asking
more serious questions and wondering
why he's actually saying these things
and i'm like dude mike pence is not
going to get arrested
mike pence is not committing treason
this is crazy what was lynnwood's claim
to fame
you told me this before he he
represented somebody that that movie uh
that just came out recently
about the guy and the and what was it he
got a cute falsely accused of planning a
bomb
you know i'm talking about richard
jewell i think what's his name richard
yeah that was atlanta bombing was that
linwood who did that i don't know
richard jewell was atlanta
there's a new breaking news happening
right now with lochner no longer
objecting
so right now it looks like they're
proceeding with the certification
mike pence was just making a speech and
it looks like they're going forward
with the vote no surprise right and then
and then here's an excellent
instance of how what happened today was
counterproductive how many dissenting
votes on the floor now
i don't know probably none none yeah
they were going is it is it is it is it
literally none or are we just i don't i
i don't know i haven't seen it it's
about to happen or it's happening right
now
stripped trump of what legitimate what
legitimacy and support
i thought rand paul said there would be
none yeah rand paul said that's it
they'll comment
it's not that i'm opposed to taking
action it's that i'm opposed to taking
stupid counterproductive
you know kamikaze without the damage to
the other side
action which is what happens i'm opposed
to general destruction and vandalism and
violence because
uh it's it's just morally wrong and i've
said this since i started doing this
work
you cannot build a better world using
the tactics of those you oppose
it's i've seen it from antifa and occupy
wall street and we're seeing this now
when you think i can create a better
world if only i use the tactics that are
wrong then you've created a world built
off of wrong tactics
and then how do you keep your glorious
revolution how do you stop the next one
right that's
that's it saying once you have your
revolution and you win and you're
victorious how do you stop the next
great revolution from happening
when occupy wall street had these black
black people they kept saying you have
to respect a diversity of tactics
and that was code for allow the violent
people and i said
no we want a better world we want a
peaceful world
we want people who will talk to each
other communicate cooperate right
you can't build that by violence you
can't build that destroying things
because what happens is
the people who are violent take power
they feel justified using violence and
then they have a brand new system that
uses violence to suppress those they
don't like
yeah and when it was going down i i
always remember saying
every action has an equal reaction and
if you think there's not going to be an
equal reaction to what's happening
especially during the summer especially
during the riots even before that we've
seen similar conflicts we've seen
the mainstream media egg it on you've
seen the mainstream media bastardize it
we've seen the mainstream media promote
certain different
uh ideas out there i i think really when
we look at the the people that are
responsible
you have to make the people who are
pointing and making people believe this
an element uh that that really should be
held responsible in my opinion
i'm worried about what the uh the
dramatic escalation is already going to
be well you know civil war is trending
on twitter so people are already talking
about this there's also people
uh talking about area 51 it's it's
trending right now as well and some
people are jokingly saying well now
maybe we could try the area 51 right
but that's again that's that's satire
and obviously facetiousness of what
people are expressing right now on
twitter and when you really look at the
hashtags uh white privilege
treason uh what else is there schumer
uh we're seeing a lot of hyperbolic
bipartisan craziness that's only going
to get more out of hand let me tell you
what i think may be
the most destructive and dangerous thing
this country has seen yet from cory bush
she's a newly elected i believe yeah
progressive
she tweeted my first resolution in
congress will be to call for the
expulsion
of the republican members of congress
who incited this domestic terror attack
on the capitol
twenty thousand retweets how many
retweets is that fifty thousand
that'll go nowhere it's not about it's
not about that it's crazy what people
people need to understand
you know when they were saying that mike
pence doesn't have the power or the
authority
it's about willpower we're human beings
we're not computer programs
what's to stop me right now from getting
up and just leaving
no people would be that's crazy tim left
his show and i was like he's not there
anymore he's got an empty chair
it's not likely to happen but i could do
it if i wanted to sure
mike pence could have walked out of the
building mike pence could have said
whatever whatever he wants
when corey bush says it's going to be a
resolution i think you're right probably
won't go anywhere
but think about the message being sent
now at a time of extreme
hyperpolarization
i will expel you i will try
to remove you she's like i'm part of the
what are they called that group of
people yeah i'm part of the squad now
she's just this like
this excessively radical uh
politician and and she's like all about
tribalism she wants to be part of this
group
and she wants to do this stupidly
radical uh
expulsion of sex listen there's there's
more hold on
she tweeted i'm calling for the removal
of every gop member involved in today's
coup
if you're with me sign your name to my
petition to send them a message that you
will not stand for their treason
do you want to know what my biggest
criticisms of this is a freshman
congressman a freshman congressman
but listen you know the problem is with
lynn woods saying mike pence committed
treason do you know the penalty for
treasonous death
death and when corey bush a sitting
member of the house who just got elected
is saying
that republicans should be expelled for
their treason
we are this is an escalation that is it
is is
listen when i have been saying that i
see this coming and i see this
escalating
i'm not saying it should happen it
shouldn't happen and people need to stop
the problem is nobody wants to be
no nobody will accept the other side
de-escalating
at all they won't okay so corey bush is
not going to say
i will be the person to say i'm calming
down we need to learn to work together
and solve this problem
some have some have i think your chinese
finger trap metaphor is fantastic
because especially if me and you both
have our fingers in the trap
if we're not talking to each other we're
not going to be able to coordinate
pushing in together
to get out together that's a really good
analogy for the tribalism
it's not just one person with their hand
stuck it's both stuck in the trap trying
to break out of it by pulling as hard as
they can
instead of talking it through calming
things down and working things out but
but the trap we're on the trap the trap
is social media the social media that
distributes images and videos and that
trigger your empathetic reactions
and sort you by tribe based on instinct
and gut so it's giving us tightening
impulses where we think the other
person's polling and when they're
actually not
algorithms and use organizations that
know if they get you in a fear state
that they get more clicks that they get
more revenue that they get more
engagement and they willingly
keep incentivizing these actions that
keep bringing us at each
other's throats and here we are today so
and and and if you haven't already smash
that like button we love your likes they
really do help
but look i i have i don't have to be an
algorithm or a news organization to
to know what you're saying is true i can
see it when i tweet about antifa and
antifa violence
mad engagement i tweet about positive
constructive things that you can do in
your life what is the alternative what
can we do what
medium engagement not nothing come on
come on but listen so so i really do
genuinely just tweet what i think
randomly sometimes i'll see something
and i'll tweet about it right
here's funny thoughts so there's there's
a bunch of tweets that i'll post that'll
do really really well
but then a good example is when i
criticize the likes of lynn wood
and i get ratioed by people who are
critical or saying well let's wait to
see how things play out
i don't i don't care if people retweet
me or not i don't ask please retweet
this
i just tweet what i'm thinking it right
sometimes my thoughts resonate with
people and sometimes they don't
but there are a lot of people who
purposefully know what they're doing and
drive it on purpose
now many of these people like to accuse
me of doing that it's just not true
yeah i just i just say what i think we
also got some other news so it looks
like the the
the chair of cpac was wrong it wasn't a
16 year old
we have the information we're getting
information from the new york post that
this
was um what specifically an air force
veteran that served in the military for
14
years and had done four tours of duty
that passed away and died today from
california tragic
that sucks wow man and you know the
problem is a lot of these people
didn't know what they were doing they
just didn't know any they didn't know
there was a video we were watching um i
was watching it on twitter
of this woman and she's crying and
someone asks her
you know what happened and she goes i
got amazed and they were like
why did you get mates and she goes we
tried entering the building and i got
two feet in and then the police maced me
and they go why were you trying to get
in the building and she goes we're
storming the capital it's a revolution
she had no idea what she was talking
about she has no idea what they were
doing foot soldiers
stooges tools pawns okay
the street soldiers for antifa are pawns
to their network
do you think the network really cares
about those antifa scrubs
i just don't want our people used as
pawns as tools
in 1800 getting into the building would
have had value because that's where all
the paperwork was
that's where the doc it's not on the
internet now it's all stored in servers
in
alaska it's something you've been
bringing up the ends like why don't they
just vote remote and they probably are
we don't even know it they have tunnels
under they don't need to be in the
capital that building's point it's
ceremonial at this point
this is that other breaking news target
carlson just said that the cabinet is
considering
invoking the 25th amendment this is from
carlson of fox news
trump's cabinet um or or the new the new
cabinet that's the that's the that's
what i'm getting right now is that the
group nancy pelosi created or whatever
or is it trump's cabinet i'm not sure
i'm gonna listen so uh in dc
they wanted i mean there's so much we
haven't even got into the pipe bombs and
stuff we gotta talk about
uh i'll tell you what really freaked me
out you know what really freaked me out
jack
when virginia announced they were
sending in virginia national guard into
a federal jurisdiction
when maryland announced they were
sending in national guard into a federal
jurisdiction
at the request of the mayor no yeah
no i saw the whole thing happen the
mayor requested virginia yeah because
the mayor requested the national guard
and the pentagon said no so then she
went and she requested local
jurisdictional help
there are fairfax county cops down there
they're montgomery county cops down
there
pence issued a statement ordering the dc
national guard to step up trump didn't
do it
wow this is what i i don't understand
why the national guard was rejected
there's a lot of confusing things for i
mean look first of all
last time there wasn't any damage like
this okay
and in in all the protests and riots
before it has been blm and antifa so
that's why they're
and and the police force escalated as
the violence escalated and they finally
escalated the police force enough to to
put it down
maybe people just didn't assume that the
maga folks were going to come and and
from the capitol i said i do my segments
10 am 1 pm 4 pm
my 1 pm segment i'm like there's a lot
of people nothing's going to happen you
know i was like they're going to trump
supporters don't do this stuff right
yeah they
have little american flags they're
they're in the ellipse they're they're
waiting for trump trump's going to speak
he's going to say his peace and they're
going to leave and then i remember like
the video goes up and then it was like 1
46 this woman gets shot or whatever and
i'm like my video's been up for 45
minutes and i said this wasn't going to
happen and it's happening right now
you incited it so it's so insane that i
could say
two things violence does not work and i
showed you the graph i showed you black
lives matter losing all their support by
rioting don't do it
and i can say i don't even think trump
supporters will do it i've been saying
for the for the week going up to it
roads are being closed so i don't know
if i'm going to go there anyway and i
don't think trump supporters
are going to do much if anything you
didn't you would assume people would say
tim was discouraging people from going
but it's this is the problem the left
and the right
to varying degrees don't care and what i
mean by that is
the left believes genuinely that the
right doesn't care and the right
believes genuinely the left doesn't care
and so both sides are unwilling to back
down
there's not going to be a compromise on
these issues and what happens when you
perpetrate one side the other side
gets even stronger and then it just
keeps going back and forth and this
continues oh well you know who loves
this is
the security apparatus they're they're
they're they're all sitting in their
private room
pop and champion dude they're already
already drafting up their brand new
counter insurgency
task force for the united states to go
after everybody
the far right the worst threat tweeted
on a maga hashtag
it's coming it's coming this this was
such a blunder i cannot emphasize this
enough
that they they were going to come after
us anyway the trumpification talk had
already begun there's no question
but now on the eve of them taking power
we have
literally we these guys storm the
capital have handed the incoming
administration
that's just the free pass to crack down
they will have the full support of the
american people
because hey there's a revolution going
on in dc
got to put it down got to put down white
supremacists the worst national
security threat according to the fbi
bull and so now they're going to have
like basically uh what what do you call
it when like
a mandate they have a mandate they will
have a mandate now to crack down
on people on speech on everything else
make everything worse loughner on the
house floor just said quote
when i arrived in washington this
morning i fully intended to object the
certification
of the electoral votes however the
events that have transpired today have
forced me to reconsider
and i cannot now in good conscience
object
so those are the comments that were just
issued okay so
who wins the only winners here
are the left private security agencies
oh yeah yeah
okay so they they won maga no one
nothing nothing is the end of manga yes
trump trump is
is they're talking about invoking the
25th what is that that's where you take
the acting president out
yup the vice president says he's unable
to do his job they remove him and i i
said earlier i would not be surprised
now if they impeach and remove as like
as like an immediate
and this is the perfect opportunity to
do it look
they claim trump was instigating all
this stuff trump trump was definitely
talking about
the evidence the election he's very
energetic but he didn't tell anybody to
go do anything i was at the speech it
was dry
and what i what i noted was that he he
did talk about some dominion and last
minute vote switching and yada yada but
he
emphasized very concrete pieces of
evidence
matt brainard type evidence you know out
of state voters dead voters whatever
he's like i'm going to bore you with all
the details because he was there to lay
out his case
even pre-faced like please don't hate me
when i'm so boring and then he pretty
much
put the ball in mike pence's court which
everyone was saying that was a pretty
weak move if you really
can't he's like he's like doing the
right thing you wouldn't put all the
responsibilities on mike pence who
publicly disagreed with you on this
particular topic so he conceded in front
of everyone
today basically he said i'll never
concede but the speech was
like he gave the ball to mike pence i
think that's fair to say right it's the
easiest way to be like i'm not conceding
it just pence isn't supporting me
i mean let's be honest here he was
already planning on a golfing trip on
the inauguration
uh during uh you know in scotland and
scotland said no because of
you know covid so there's also that
important merit to bring up here and
people should also understand
i think this is the uh i think it's i
think it's the end
do you disagree well no i was just
shaking my i don't know if i agree or
not but i was shaking my head at the
idea that
this moment is the worst possible thing
that could happen to the emergent
trump nationalist populism that was
trying to form trying to come out of
this
stop the steal stop the steal could have
been literal could have been
metaphorical just the same way build the
wall was literal and
metaphorical pulling back from globalism
and you know erecting barriers in
general
stop the steal stop them from stealing
our government stop the critical race
here from taking over the government
stop the radical left from taking over
institutions
i can see that so there was like a seed
there's energy
and then something like this is bad bad
jews bad jews for the for the energy
uh jack i got bad news for you tell me
you're the number five
top trending uh uh hashtag is on twitter
right now
uh ef around to find out white privilege
by white privilege white privilege oh
because uh that white chick got shot for
storm in the capital
uh probably because they're what what
they've been saying is look what happens
when black lives matter protests they
get all these different
things here's that all night i mean look
it's actually a fair point but not
necessarily for
entirely what they're saying they're
saying when black lives matter comes to
the to the capitol they go crazy
with mass security right that's true
they didn't do that this time
but guess who loses in the end it's the
manga it's trump supporters well trump
wouldn't call in the national guard he
denied
the mayor nationals no no no
no no the national guard said no
to the request are you sure they said no
yes
denied i mean i saw reports on twitter
and then the follow-on events
line up to me to to say that this was
likely to have happened in that they
went to the national guard first
no now they call it cops from loudoun
chris miller is what i uh but chris
miller reports to trump so
there's a whole lot that could happen
there what i heard was that the national
guard has already had already been given
orders on how they were assisting local
law enforcement when the mayor came in
and said we want you to move they said
that's got to go through standardized
procedure so we can't do that
trump did not say give up
give them the request mike pence
eventually stepped in and said do it and
then they did so trump didn't do it yeah
there's so much fake news and nonsense
out there i mean i don't know if even i
should address this
uh specifically with what keith oberman
just said
oh no but you won't do it come
he said quote the united states of
america was today the victim of a
terrorist attack orchestrated by the
president of the united states today
donald trump's 9 11 attack on america
he's comparing what happened yeah keith
olbermann's
9 11. he reminds me of that guy uh
in the french revolution remember that
writer the friend of the people i think
was
his news
and this yeah stabbed him and martyred
him basically
yeah and caused so i i like i mean i
like keith a little bit but
this rhetoric that he's been spewing the
last like he's five years since he went
crazy since he got kicked out of his uh
his old job with who was at msnbc when
he got fired
and this was the dumbest terrorist
attack in the history of terror attacks
a terror attack with a net result of
negative one dead
or a girl dead and your whole intent and
purposes being shot to [ __ ] all the same
time
what kind what is that that's why i
wonder about the police just letting
them in
i want to know more about that i'm going
to talk to my guys and see what they
have to say about that
they definitely there's videos of them
smashing the windows like the cops
weren't letting them in the building let
me see if i can
but they smashed the windows out they
were climbing and scaling those walls
they were going through awnings we need
to get those rivets out of the walls by
the way
that you can climb up yeah i've always
thought about that they walk by flat
shear walls out
so you can't get over them like who who
whoever was designing the capital they
were like
i think we need a ladder to get on to
get into the capitol grounds here so
let's make this wall climbable what's
crazy let's make it look good no one
it's gotta have like gonna look pretty
it's gotta have those pigeon things on
it so people can't climb it you know
what i mean there's a little yeah
trump is banned from facebook for 24
hours yeah
yep twitter 12 hours facebook this is
the end of
trump's i think they're going to go
after them at legally
i know i think new york's going to try
to arrest him they're going to try and
shut down the organization
they they they did not want this man to
win and i tell you in
what we've seen here you know what i was
saying earlier when i said nothing's
going to happen
i was like look we went through four
years of the left screaming trump's
illegitimate he didn't win and these
scandals and i was like what's
what's the likelihood that we get the
same thing now with republicans saying
oh joe biden and scandals and ukraine
and that now we're seeing trump
supporters clashing with cops
like we saw with antifa i think it was i
said it was going to be like an
inversion this is not
this is something twisted and weird ha
this puts the
banning of enrique into a new light
doesn't it
why is that well because maybe he would
have been on the ground telling people
to chill the f
out i don't think he was going down into
dc thinking that they were going to
storm the capital
yeah in fights whenever you take down
the leadership the
the you know army usually is chaotic
doesn't know what these people are going
to
shout out to john gary for that comment
on twitter
thank you very much and then uh another
thing i was thinking about today
is uh i noticed after the speech there
were just
gangs and i don't want to use okay let
me take that back
there were large groups of angry people
dressed in black
and they had shirts you know f antifa
then there was other group and they were
just marching around f and t for
evantiva and then another group and i'm
not disparaging these people are saying
it's wrong i'm just saying that energy
was different today
then there was multiple groups carrying
with you know like uh
football sized uh flags american flags
all holding a piece of it over their
head walking down the streets chanting
who streets our streets who streets our
feet we keep
us safe exactly they stole all the
antifa chance i saw multiple groups like
that you see the
i heard reports that there were leftists
and conservatives chanting after police
i don't know if that's true though well
i'm telling you man my twitter mentions
yesterday went a-cap
like i couldn't believe it from trump
supporters yeah from my own people i
block a bunch of people i don't care
i think i think antifa is going to
become a a
a i don't want to say it's going to like
not bipartisan isn't the right word
but i wouldn't be surprised like when
you when you when enrique tario tweeted
that
proud boys are just like antifa what's
the stop now conservatives from being
like
okay yeah i think cerno tweeted this
afternoon this was
the birth of the right-wing antifa uh
john robb today tweeted out that uh this
was the
first the first uh mobilization for the
right-wing tribal network uh he
actually asked me yesterday dm's how's
mobilization looking and i didn't i
couldn't tell him
but i saw it today man it's there the
acab is in effect now i'm feeling it all
over the place
the the the uh you know back the blue
seems to be history
phase shift in the network uh
practically overnight had to joan norman
on that one
uh and then this violence against the
cops and storming in the federal
buildings i mean
like the whole environment shifted today
did you see the video
of i tell you the craziest thing i've
ever seen there's someone holding a thin
blue line flag
in front of a and right in front of them
in this huge crowd as a cop being
shoved and beaten by a bunch of trump
supporters did you see that video
no i don't know if he was being beaten
per se but he was being roughed up
it's this um dragged out of the building
apparently this story of becoming the
demon that you
despise have you seen the watchman the
movie there's a cartoon in it where this
guy goes out to sea
and these these demons attack his boat
and take him and then they're going to
kill his wife back home so he
he he has these visions and he just
wants to kill this demon so he finally
you know he's sailing back to save his
wife and he's just obsessed with
destroying this demon
he gets back and it's nighttime and he's
searching for his wife and he sees the
demon and he kills it
and then he realizes when the light
comes on that the the demon was his wife
and he became so obsessed with
destruction and destroying this evil
thing that
he became the evil thing what's the uh
what's the saying be careful when
fighting monsters lest you become one
for when you gaze into the abyss the
abyss gazes back i mean at the end of
the summer i stopped going out
uh to film the riots partially because
my profile was getting so big that i was
getting id'd everywhere i went but
mostly because
i felt it inside me that i
wanted something bad to happen what do
you mean like i'm going i'm leaving my
kids at home i'm going out on the street
i'm staying out until two in the morning
like they call it firefighters wishing
for fire
yeah i had an urge i had an urge to want
to see it of course i tweeted at home
thank god there's no violence
it's there's this idea that you've got a
firefighter whose job
what makes them feel good is saving
people from a burning building is
putting the fire out being the hero
doing their job
makes you feel good during 9 11 there's
reports that
they would have to take first responders
and partially bury them so the dogs
would feel a sense of like joy for
rescuing a person because they couldn't
find people
the dogs would eventually get depressed
because they couldn't find anybody that
they were doing something wrong
so there's this idea where you know
you're a firefighter and you sit around
all day doing nothing
and then one day you're sitting there
going like come on give me a fire and
you realize how crazy that is
and there's no it's a good thing there's
no firemen no you stopped i stopped
tim you stopped but what about the
average mainstream media a lunky who
can't stop and has to keep doing this so
what was that movie where they had that
reporter that was
uh that became obsessive and he started
creating conflict just so he could get
the
you know the video of that movie it
is literally in my opinion that is
literally happening right now but on a
big mainstream media level
and they are foaming at the mouth loving
and seeding all of this and this is
their
this is their kind of big holiday have
you seen the movie night crawler with
jake gyllenhaal no but we have discussed
this before and i understand the
character arc there and i felt i'm
telling you i felt so check this out
check this out
um spoiler alert but it's an older movie
so you should have seen it actually
we got to talk about this because in in
the movie you basically have this dude
who's clearly a sociopath
and he's broke and he's trying to find
any job he can he's trying to sell like
stolen medals or whatever
he can't get a job and he's trying to
make money until he
he stumbles upon night crawling which is
this what
it's journalists who go out in the
middle of the night and they chase down
car crashes and murders and crimes
he ends up selling a tape for some good
money he eventually starts making better
and better money
eventually he realizes he actually sees
a car crash he moves one of the bodies
to get a better shot it looks better
this way
it sells for even more at one point he
withholds evidence
and now he's actively finally
orchestrating
events that that are death and murder
because it pays the best this
this is the craziness that we see i
personally feel
there are many people in media sitting
there crossing their fingers
hoping this would happen definitely you
see it even just in the subtly
or sorry on twitter i just see it in the
little typing texts like
where you'll see like the people with
their cameras just like recording the
empty streets
waiting for something like that it's
almost vitriolic right now
because there's a subreddit called why
were they filming and it makes you
wonder about things like this why were
they filming what were they waiting for
what do they want to happen i mean it's
the difference of
like uh taking a picture of a dumpster
from the side with all the lights and
the flash on a fl
the fire in the dumpster and then you
know getting into position getting down
on the ground low to the ground turning
off the lights like
having it look overexposed and having it
look like this giant inferno
that's the same concept at work right
there's a very very very famous moment
it's a photo of i believe it's a haitian
girl and she's lying on the ground dead
and this photo it's like from low and
it's pointing up you see the sky you see
people walking past
but there's an even more famous photo
that emerged from this
one of the photographers who was taking
a picture of the girl
got up and walked to the side and took a
picture of a
row of photographers around this corpse
this dead young girl
taking the pictures and that in my
opinion is one of the most iconic photos
of the past you know 500 years or
whatever
the real image that you didn't see while
these these journalists were trying to
get the artistic shot of this
this young dead woman the real image was
all of these
vultures lining up around to get that
shot to make money to sell it
that's how scary it is but here's the
thing
when you take these pictures i'll tell
you one of the most important things
you want to know what the least the
biggest letdown of my life
in terms of my expectations you ever see
the meme reality versus uh
expectation versus reality is being in a
revolut it was witnessing a revolution
right in front of my eyes in egypt
i thought revolution was gonna be like
you see these movies and the french
revolution and
the people are running through the
streets and you know they're capturing
the nobles
in egypt there's a few thousand people
jumping up and down as like music played
and then they announced the news they
have removed uh the president from power
that was it
and then they were like so the
revolution happened and i was like
that's it you're like that's it
revolution happened i was like okay
what did you think what do you think it
was going to be like when these
journalists
take these film these things and they
inflate it they make it look
bigger and crazier and more dramatic it
makes people think things are worse than
they really are
the one thing i always tell people when
it comes to egypt i was standing on my
balcony
looking at tahrir square apache
helicopters flying overhead
lasers everywhere they announced the
revolution was underway
and right down on the grounds of
mcdonald's and a guy was eating a burger
watching a soccer match
like nothing was happening you'd hop on
the back of a motorcycle
go down the street go to the shopping
mall like nothing was happening but
people have this
this view that's created by
sensationalized news
where all the history and so and
absolutely history is condensed
and so one of the things i always you
know i took issue with
when portland was was being hit by those
riots for a hundred plus days
you had two versions of it well i don't
even i don't want to say two versions
but the mainstream media was saying
there's nothing going on in portland and
they'd walk around like everything's
fine
in new york with the lockdowns and
everything you have these videos popping
up of leftists walking in like the upper
west side saying look everything's fine
people are having ice cream
and they ignore the actual strife and
conflict that is happening
because in their view they're like
everybody's exaggerating fox news is
lying to you
and it's like look just because fox news
or any journals for that matter is
showing you something happening
doesn't mean you should assume it's
happening literally everywhere
but people do they do assume that it's
crazier than it really is
there's like a belief that a revolution
is like a moment where like you seized
the idol and now you have it
and the revolution is over but like a
revolution is a long process of change
and it's a constant it's like a way of
life but you know what this is all in
our heads
the constitution is words or ideas in
our head the regime is an idea in our
head it's an imagined order
a revolution changes the imagined order
in your head yes it's got practical
realities of course but like you're
still going to be sitting there
we're still going to eat the combos
we're still going to have the beans let
me let me tell you the most important
thing humans need to understand human
beings
they said mike pence doesn't have the
power to reject the electors
sure the constitution says you know
basically here's how the count goes
the constitution also says shall not be
infringed
constitution also says the right to
peaceably assemble shall not be
accomplished congress shall make no law
infringing you know
our bridging the right to peaceably
assemble the right to worship but here
we are
cuomo has done that right and that's and
that's under the
under the uh a state of emergency so
what people need to realize
is well for one there's the hypocrisy
there's the double standard
one the rules apply to pence he can't do
anything but the rules don't apply to
the democratic governors
more importantly i think that should
show you if you believe in the
constitution it only goes as far as
other people agree with you
that's confidence in the system in order
for any political movement to have
traction there must be confidence behind
it
that's it the moral element of fourth
generation
war but i think it's i think confidence
is breaking down right now
and that's why we saw what we did today
yeah along with the lines of like um
reporters
seeking out violence and chaos so that
they can sell their things it makes me
think like
the girl that got shot today was
ex-military and so she's
maybe trained to find and destroy
violence and looking for it and so she's
going to this looking for a heated you
know something to fight
you know they're trained that there's an
enemy out there and when they're not in
in combat anymore when they're not
deployed anymore there's still this
mentality of i got to find the enemy i
got to destroy the
and i wonder it's not fair to think
about her intentions right now we don't
know but i wonder how many i don't know
what was going on
i still don't know the information i
wonder how many of those people were
ex-military that were there today
looking for an enemy
well more importantly how many people
were larping
yup that's like more that's more
important ex-military the ex-military
i've talked to
and the ones that have actually seen
combat tell you that
it's nothing you want to see it's
nothing you want to be participating in
you want to avoid it at all costs
i got to i got to tell you having seen
people get shot in front of me
i'm surprised there are people who would
be willing to run towards that
like i i look as a journalist on the
ground and you're covering conflict in
crisis
there's a certain degree to which you're
like i have to film this people have to
see it
but there's a big difference between
what i would do say on the ground during
conflicts riots or even civil unrest in
other countries
versus actively participating in the
conflict and running towards the
violence to engage in it yeah and i
don't mean in a bad way i mean like
you're a soldier you're a cop you see
people fighting and shooting and you
think to yourself i'm going to
engage in that conflict journalists
don't do that i didn't do that
when i'd be on the ground in these
countries i would see it i'd be like i'm
going to hide behind this pillar and
point my camera at it
and run away if it gets too intense and
i'm in danger
one of the things that i've been saying
for a very long time whenever you have
to resort to
to violence that should always be your
last resort because everyone loses when
that happens and
people need to realize that another
thing that i kind of wanted to bring up
here
is again just on this topic of
mainstream media journalists kind of
wanting this conflict
there's a tweet here that i'm seeing
right now by sally cohan that was
tweeted
june 30th and she said quote
i don't like violent protests but i
understand them
and those wagging their finger against
violent protests
need to read up on their american
history today
she's saying that what happened was an
absolute outcry she's detesting it
and now she's saying that she hopes
republicans never win another national
or statewide election for a generation
and she of course is detesting this that
the fullest extent
of how disgusting and bad it is so again
this is the system this is the
establishment this is the mainstream
media voices
that are promoted on on youtube these
are the the voices that are allowed
these are the authoritarian voices that
are saying yes violent protests are good
and now we're here today come on
let's have a real serious discussion
about the the the steps that led us here
and how we could walk away from this in
a rational way rather than of course
continuing this left-right hyperbolic
nonsense which is again
going to expand from here i don't know
none of this strikes me as new
americans are hot-headed we fight we
have wars we fight each other we're
tribal
politics have been rough and tumble
forever
i mean i don't know it doesn't happen it
doesn't strike me as being a historic it
doesn't strike me as being
out of the norm what it is for american
politics exacerbated because we've been
at war for 20 years and it's been
normalized this girl didn't even go into
the military until
2006. if she's been in the navy was the
navy air force
for uh six 14 years since 2006 five
years after the the forever war just
began and
and now so these people are brainwashed
to think that conflict is normal
and and now we've seen all this domestic
upheaval
as a result of these of these people
with psychosis
essentially so you trace it to the
military involvement because i would
trace it directly to social media
and schools which tim kind of discounts
i think the schools are hugely important
i do i think
the social media is uh piggybacking on
it to to exacerbate it but the school
system that rockefeller built in the 20s
and 30s was basically to turn people
into corporate drones and follow orders
and join the military
so that i think this is definitely
factory workers right raise your hand
wait till the bell rings don't do
anything unless you're
you're given permission i don't know man
america was settled by conquerors we
conquered the land we conquered the
people we've been to wars we fought
we're so antagonistic we fought a
freaking civil war
we fought ourselves we thought ourselves
were so antagonistic it's like built
right into the system i think
and i think that it's i know frankly i'm
getting a little tired
of of just okay yeah the left's
hypocritical
yeah okay the left wants to i mean we
know like we know and everybody knows
and i don't want to spend the next four
years talking about like and no offense
dude but like you know
comparing people's tweets yeah they're
all hypocritical we we all
are too exactly we all are too so i
guess the question that i've been
getting a lot and the question that
uh people were dming me on my way up
here it's like well we're not the
institutional power we're not the
authoritative sources we're not the
sources that are out there to
millions and millions and millions of
people we're independent media telling
people
we're wrong sometimes we admit our
faults they don't that's the problem
and they have a huge voice that
galvanizes and supports and beats the
drum for conflict that's a big
difference
so yes we are hypocrites on some levels
everyone is no one's a perfect
principled person but they're
they're something else not just
hypocrites in my opinion i sat here with
you
and i said the proud boys starting to
look like antifa remember
and i heavily criticized for the same
exact reasons destruction of private
property
going around beating people attacking
people who are retreating all that stuff
when we when we do a show and the people
i respect we criticize
the violent behavior because i i tell
this story all the time
one of my favorite stories is is when i
shook the hands of a guy wearing a
sickle and hammer mask a commie
giving out communist literature because
he told me violence is wrong
and i was like my man i shook his hand
and i said that's awesome you want to
have a conversation about marxism and
communism and all that stuff we could
sit down and
debate ideas i love it that's so cool
the moment you go around and say i'm
right there for your
you're morally justified is when you are
you are wrong and you are bad and that's
a problem
so here's the problem though and and i
agree with that
in the back of my head i can hear all
the people going yeah that's how
how we got in this mess that's how we
got in this mess so what do you do
by by like taking the high ground as it
were and not con you know condoning
violence which i don't i disavow all the
political violence in fact
even if you want political violence you
should disavow all political violence
all the way up until the time you commit
it not that i'm advocating for it
because i'm not disavow
it's just violence it just doesn't work
it's just but what do you do when you
realize that you're in an engagement
where the other side believes in
political violence i'll ask you a
question what do you do then that that's
what people are asking me
right yes and i can answer them okay so
uh
let's let's let's do a stereotypical uh
ancient or feudal japan
when the war was breaking out between
you know rival
factions did the you know did one side
send in the warriors to march right into
the feudal lord's house and then declare
that they were going to duel him and
finally end this conflict once and for
all
or did ninja dress up in civilian
clothes pre-plan
and subvert the strategy of their
opponent going in and removing the
feudal lord in the dead of night
and then running across the water with
wood placed in
specific positions so that it looked
like they were walking on water freaking
out the enemies and then dropping i
think it's called makabishi
caltrops essentially with poison in them
they planned ahead
they considered what they were up
against and they made a surgical move
we are in an era where we are we have
i i think this is actually i think
there's a good thing here that we are
moving past the era of violence
it's actually kind of cool if you think
about it right that our our engagements
are now
based upon ideas and propaganda and
confidence
and that means it really does come down
to being smart
being strategic uh uh
you know your strategy in terms of how
you apply your resources how you accrue
resources how you distribute them
and how you convince people to
contribute to your ideology
that's how you win an ideological war i
think you're 100 right and i think that
a new life skill that people have to
develop
is personal sovereignty and by that i
mean being aware of
your ideas electing to choose the ideas
that you do believe in and repelling
ideas that seek to capture your mind
and that starts with being like
physically mentally emotionally
spiritually strong
integrated as as whole making good
choices understanding what your values
are and even and being able to
to to embody them in your life and to
manifest more of those
in the world around you and that's what
we do in the liberal order personal
sovereignty is one of the number one
things that we focus on
in liminal order check it out you know
what we're going to be doing
we're going to be getting a big old
farmland we're going to be making videos
where we build stuff
where we're going to have fun we're
going to skateboard we're going to drive
atvs
and the goal of this is there's two
really big things i keep saying
you want to you want to look we talk so
much about negative stuff all the time
on this show as me personally i do like
four hours or three hours every day and
there's always something negative
so i'm like i gotta have a balance you
know yin yang man there's gotta be some
good coming out of this
so i wanna we wanna create we have the
space we wanna create stuff we to
encourage people to build and better
themselves and exercise and eat right
and eat healthy and all that good stuff
amen brother and so i think one of the
one of the most important things we can
do is
self-sufficiency amen fulfilling our
goals and i think one of the things that
you know a woman right hey men a woman
and and eight children too yes
so we're looking at getting this land
and then we're gonna have fun and be
positive and productive
totally tim we're on such the same vibe
dude like i've been looking at land for
a while as you know
i think that was one of the first things
we talked about the very first time i
came on the show back in philly last
year homesteading yeah homesteading 90
acres for your 50 000 walled feudal
village
that's a little bit more than i know i
know but like in like
people are asking me what can you do and
the thing that you can do is what we're
doing in the liminal order we decided a
few years ago that the way we're going
to fight back against this
is by by doubling down on ourselves and
our families and our communities and
building something positive
engaging your masculine sense of
creation and protection
and instruction so we're building a
community where people help each other
and we're getting fitter and we're
getting wealthier and we're getting
happier and we're stronger and we're
more secure
and we have a network off of the social
media networks we have private network
that can't be disrupted
and we all are talking about
self-sufficiency we're all looking at
homesteading we're all looking at trying
to
i like to say resettle the american
frontier there's a lot of land
out there so much and there's a lot of
opportunity and there's a lot of places
that will
welcome you warmly i owe main calls dude
there's so many places that call all of
them have a red color
to their state on the map for sure think
about this the the the pilgrims the
pioneers
who came from europe to the new world
and what would what what the first
people who came what could you expect
our boat is going to land and there's
going to be trees and shoreline
and then once we land have at it what
were they expecting to find
no they realized like how many people
died not even
making it across the ocean like a
three-month journey where is that spirit
today of people being like
i'm gonna i'm gonna move to nebraska in
the middle of nowhere to a small town
that needs help and start building
something and and you know bringing that
life back to these areas or
starting my own you know a place my own
home and
living like the brave people who found
new places and
you know so the future for that and
bellagi talks about this and we talk
about this in liminal order as well
you got to build a community based on
values you start a virtual community
based on values
and then you build the community and the
norms and then you have the
relationships and the resources
and then you can find land and then you
can start to homestead places
you know there there uh there is a
positive with all the lockdowns
it's true and i don't want to pretend
like um everything's always been
everything's absolute
a lot of people are now realizing they
have to be self-sustainable
they can't rely on the government who
can't get them a stimulus who
actually shut down their businesses but
let me tell you if you lived out in the
middle of nowhere
and you were self-sufficient you were
less impacted by the lockdowns
most people still were to certain
degrees but the further you move away
from the cities
the less you actually see in terms of
that damage from the population density
so i think one of the one of the
positives we may be getting out of this
and i think
the other point i was going to make
about what we want to do is encourage
people to be
energy efficient and self-sustainable so
what that means is
you really want to get out in the middle
of nowhere and save money especially in
a crisis
you've gotta you gotta get better forms
of energy better energy production
self-sufficient
i mean dude water wheels come on you
know use a stream turn a turbine make
your own make your own electricity or
something like that
ride a bike there's a lot of things we
can do that uh i think for a long time
humans have been
kind of just accepting of you know it's
easy come easy go
and now a lot of people are realizing
well for one you can't really rely on
the government
stimulus checks is the perfect example
they couldn't get that done and then the
democrats end up winning georgia
so maybe you need to sit back and take
care of yourself obviously i think most
conservatives understand that 100
percent the left that is now starting to
learn that lesson a little bit
do you think or they're like woo hoo all
the reds are leaving the cities
they're running away to fly over land
you know i wonder if they'll learn their
lesson
because they're they're staying in
california they're staying in new york
where they're just
like getting no support getting locked
down i mean that's not entirely true
california had net
out migration i think for the first time
ever they're probably conservatives
it is they're they're losing uh a
congress a house seat i think in
with the next census here uh so you know
people are going to be voting with their
feet but
look i've done the research uh global
globalism's impact on the united states
and that
in the theory of global trade is that
the labor mobility
is free and that people will move to
where the best opportunities are we just
haven't seen that it's just not true
it's just not true labor mobility is not
a real thing people stay even when the
factory closes
people say even when the drugs are
killing everybody they still stay
europe is a good example i think i told
the story we talked about this last time
where i was in greece
and i was in an uber and the guy was
telling me about how the economy was
totally destroyed
and i was like but can't you as a member
of the eu just go to the uk or germany
where the economy is better
and he said but i'm greek i want to stay
in greece
so the economy is destroyed there's no
money there's no jobs but you don't want
to leave
i get it they don't want to do it but i
wonder like
you know what was it that made the uh uh
the european colonizers
decide to get on a boat risk their lives
and go to a big empty
they got shunned they were kicked out
what are you talking about they were
hated well there you go our trump
supporters gonna be like let's go make
you know uh freedomville
in in wyoming mars yeah greenland uh
yeah greenland
all the trump supporters should now uh
migrate to greenland i tell you
they will be doing that on mars i've
been watching vikings and i'm telling
you that looks like a horrible place
yeah
greenland no thank you i wonder at what
point did they stop saying i'm texan and
start saying i'm american
do they now i don't know usually yeah
like i'm in ohio and first
well i think texas is a particular case
because they were a nation
i'm a virginian i think there's only a
few states a few states that are like
that virginia is one of them
you know people think that they're a
virginian before they're at what point
will we stop being like i'm an american
first and an earthen
you know a terran next or when we're
going to start thinking of ourselves as
like
this is my planet or when we go to mars
and we're like i'm a martian i'm a
terran
and 100 200 years people like when
there's a couple generations of people
from mars
at what point would be like i don't know
i'm a solar
i don't think we're gonna do it i think
i think we'll go there i think i think
colonize in the sense that we'll
probably have some production
but i don't think humans will live there
have you seen the weather there it sucks
if you melt the uh i'm going to the
beach i'm not going to mars and by the
way
it would take 10 million dollars to pay
me to go into space
so you think no way yeah if someone said
hey man you want to go on the next
rocket to the space shuttle or
space station no no 10 million
that's what it would take to get me into
space everything sucks
you think people will uh will start to
think of themselves as a terran
but that we need some external threat
you don't think that we'll just do that
because we want to be all one world
this is our home you can go anywhere i
mean maybe it comes down to language if
you can speak the language of a
different might be human country
if aliens come they'll be like human i
think
didn't we talk about the fact that we
think that we it's fun to say that the
aliens would unite us
but they probably would but they
probably absolutely not no trump
supporters would be like do the aliens
support freedom and the left would be
like do the aliens support communal
social welfare programs
and then which big one and then the
aliens are going to be like do you
support
floor neck we're going to be like we
don't know what that is then you must be
ended and then the aliens go to war with
us and then we unite yeah the reason i
bring it up is because i don't like
nationalism i don't like tribalism in
general i'm kind of over it i want a
global
it got you here bro got you here your
tribe got you into it
it did but that doesn't mean we have to
keep doing it so but here's the problem
a lot of violence
good good luck good so good luck
convincing antifa
that you shouldn't be forced to live the
way they want you to live
like what do you do if someone walks up
to you and says you are now going to
adhere to all of our rules or else
do you say okay this is why we're in a
bad spot we're
forced to play a game that we don't want
to play right
and we're playing rules that we by rules
that we don't want to play by
which is the other side thinks that
political violence is okay they're
willing to trash people and the media
allows it and
right and and they believe that they're
morally justified and that we're morally
inferior and that we believe to be
executed for treason so at some point we
have to just accept that we're playing a
game we don't want to play
with rules that we don't like and we
also there's no option here's here's the
issue
you've i think i think us you know for a
show like this and the people who watch
we're all relatively in the middle in
terms of just kind of like chilling
and having conversations but then you
have the far left and the far right
and to whatever extent they're far left
and far right just further left and
further right
when the left looks over to the right
they see us
all having a conversation and behind us
they see the right you see what i'm
saying
so this is i'll give you the real the
real uh story when i was in
boston during this big protest the bunch
of trump supporters
behind them was a guy waving a
confederate flag when i talked to the
democrat uh democratic socialist guys
they said look at them they're waving a
confederate flag and i said
well that's one guy in the back the
people in front
aren't and he was like but it's just one
big group and i was like
really is it the same was true for this
group in the
in uh there was a bunch of like lefty
protesters and then there was a row of
antifa
with you know crowbars and bats wearing
all black you go and talk to the trump
supporters they go look at them
they're they're they're supporting these
extremists with crowbars and bets and i
was like
what happens is the people on the left
when they look to their right
they don't understand the depth of
difference between the center and the
far right
they don't they just see to them it's
one group all standing around
on the right yeah that's the uh
phenomena of depth perception and you
can't see depth perception with one eye
you need two eyes and if you're one of
the eyes then you need an external
feedback source to understand the other
and it can't be the other it's got to be
that's why
understanding other people's triangles
so here's my point listen listen
you you we had uh lynn wood saying mike
pence committed treason
and and roberts and all that stuff you
do have
elements of the trump right who say
things like treason
and and sedition calling cops treasonous
and traitors
and it's it's really funny when i'm
seeing the trump supporters say you're a
traitor to the cop and i'm like yeah the
left says the same thing
you know i'm not saying their ideals are
the same or their principles are the
same or their actions are the same but
there's similarities in the words they
use who streets our streets and things
like that
what ends up happening is it's like i
described
you know regular people in the middle
the left will look at us and call us all
far right
you're the all you're all the same it's
like well we don't want any of the
violence we just want to chill hang out
and you know work and
feed our families and kind of have a
good time but peace
love kindness and all that stuff i don't
know man we kill animals for
a living to survive to eat their meat
well yeah because violence that's
racist life is this animal have you seen
nature destruction
well hold on hate each other chaotic and
so listen listen
the fundamental argument that i take
issue with with it like oh but we kill
animals well of course we do animals
kill each other for food all the time
humans are animals not that we eat each
other well we probably i don't see
anybody complaining that lion just ate
that gazelle
right i'm actually i'm sure super
violent but we don't have any issue with
it because they're not human for some
reason
and we don't have issue of humans eating
cows right because we have to enforce
the fact that we're at the top of the
food chain
but if humans eat humans we go crazy
because that's more of humans eating
because of uh encephalopathy is that
what it's called
or encephalitis why people hate that
humans eat dogs in
in the us but not interesting why
because they mimic little children
that's just like that isn't how violence
is okay sometimes if the military
authorizes it's totally fine
if it's not authorized though then it's
wrong no no no no no you must understand
i think most of us here are
opposing war and conflict and don't want
that to happen
the issue is there are other people that
love it neocons and neolibs are like
more war don't let trump pull the troops
out
we gotta be in syria i think that's a
bad thing i think it's stupid
that's why i'm like you know what man
here's the challenge let's let's let's
get away from
the the current events and talk about
the general bigger picture
how do you do what's right to save the
world or whatever and when are you
morally justified in doing so if the
democrats and the republicans together
vote for war
and then send american soldiers overseas
and their civilians are dying
whether through you know uh malicious
intent or negligence from american
soldiers and our allies
oil is being taken poppy fields are
being guarded all this really awful
stuff
and no one in america seems to be able
to do anything about it
do we just say well i'm gonna go you
know get a farm and just ignore
everything
how do you fight to stop really really
bad things from happening
this is a serious moral challenge we
could just say
all this bad stuff's happening i'm out
i'm not going to be involved
you know i want to mind my own business
but what do you do all it takes for what
was that saying all it takes for for
evil to succeed is for a good amendment
to do
nothing are you asking like if we
observe an evil occurring in the world
why don't we go and take care of it is
that what we're saying i'm just saying
like
it's it's it's really difficult to have
um i i guess i'll put it this way this
is a system built by billions of people
that all kind of agree inadvertently or
otherwise
and it's hard to stop the system from
doing what it does
and so it's easy to just be like
walk away from it and then fighting to
change it seems to be futile for a lot
of people
and i mean like you know politics and
voting and protests all the protests we
had against war like what did that
accomplish
not a whole lot we're still there it's
tough to say maybe we'd be it more if we
didn't protest it's true
yeah maybe we'd be at more if people
didn't vote for trump the top of the
food chain argument we all kind of agree
with that
as a human you know how how do we that's
a dangerous it's whatever our
self-interest
is that's what happens that's why we get
interested in the middle east oh we're
energy dependent oh and we want to
protect democracy in israel the problem
with uh self-motivated we have people
right now that are telling us the
world's on fire
resources are being depleted so we have
to great reset right and kova is the
perfect opportunity to do it the only
problem is china isn't
they're they're they're doing all of the
same stuff so
what what ends up happening we agree to
chill out and calm down
not spend stuff and go live sustainably
and then in 100 years
everyone's pumping oil and gas like
crazy because china has taken influence
over
you know taking the influence in the
planet on the planet the most influence
and now everyone's just kind of living
the way they want them to live and
they're going to keep producing
greenhouse gases and carbon emissions
and all that stuff
people in america and europe claim is
bad that's why it's just like
it feels like we're on a collision
course and that's why i often say
you know it not not to be pessimistic
but i remember it was only a few weeks
ago
when something happened with like some
political violence and i said
look i can tell you that maybe it all
ends here maybe this is the time it
finally stops because everyone says it's
gone too far
or maybe it escalates because people
want retribution in revenge
is violence the natural order of being
human are we
should we just accept it but then that's
like you can't just no i said
i said earlier i think we're revolving
past it it doesn't work the
enlightenment has brought us out of
barbarism what has what has incited so
many
how did trump get elected partly because
of far-left riots and protesting not
being taken seriously and people getting
mad about it
it was a big culture war issue with you
know hands up don't shoot and things
like that
now we have like you know luke mentioned
sally cohn or whatever saying
you know that oh she doesn't like him
but you got to understand them and you
have jake
cuomo saying who said protests had to be
you know peaceful or whatever it's right
there in the first amendment just look
it up cuomo
you have that and it creates an
opposition where they're like how dare
you
say these things are okay and people get
mad about it so i think i think violence
is becoming less and less effective and
it's a great thing because we want to
get rid of it
and uh you know ultimately i guess i
wonder where
you know where where we'll be led to but
the point i'm trying to make is for now
i don't think it's a natural order of
things i think it is phasing out but
just because it's phasing out doesn't
mean we won't see
an escalation it's a different kind of
violence it's a violence in your brain
it's a violence in your heart it's a
violence for control of your thoughts of
your emotions
it's more invasive in some ways it's
like this i'm sorry it's like that star
trek the old one where like
they didn't have war anymore they just
like everybody like went to their
chamber to receive their like
you know dose of misery or whatever what
i'm saying is
you go back several hundred years and
you see these memes where people are
like the founding fathers would have
been you know storming the gates by now
or something like that and it's like
yeah back then we don't do that now
however you can still see a ton of
violence just because violence is
receding overall doesn't mean it's not
going to increase in the short term
what i'm saying is after today does
anyone think things are going to get
calmer
and this is finally the moment where
everyone says wow we should stop and
everyone should chill out and hug and
unify
no not with the rhetoric on the
mainstream media no
corey bush is saying that republicans
committed treason for supporting the
president i don't think we're bystanders
to
whatever happens i think we're creating
it and we're altering
our path right now especially when you
have this internet video where we can
reach i don't know 100 000 people at
once a million people at once in a
second
we can all think the same thing for a
second so
maybe maybe we could make a peaceful
future
maybe we can convince a hundred thousand
people to uh make graphene
oh yeah i wanna do like um like make an
or
make a giant campus where we can have
every american tax
fund it together and then everyone can
go there for a couple weeks uh in their
lifetime to learn how to use lasers to
create graphing
and then all the graphing that we
produce with our taxpayer money will
be free for the people to recoup so when
we start selling cars with graphene
bodies
we'll discount the cost of the body off
of the car for the people
well we're going to get this big old
farmland and we're going to build a
bunch of fun stuff and we're going to
have lasers
airplanes and jet packs and i'm on my
way i'm on my way as well i'm i'm
taking a timber framing course this
summer i want to learn how to do timber
framing because i want to be able to go
to the land drop down the tree mill it
on site
build the structure with the tree from
the site chopped
felled and milled and built on site
that's my that's my plan that's my 2021
goal to become basic did you see chris
martinson on the show
last week peak prosperity
yeah we gotta have you guys on together
sometimes yes it's on farm
let's do it let's do it i love that guy
hey tim can i bring my chainsaw up here
and practice chopping down trees on your
property
one more time can i bring my chainsaw up
here and practice chopping down trees on
your property
it's conservation sadly but once we're
in west virginia and we have to have the
trees taken down we're gonna need some
help i was really expensive i was
looking at like
maybe could i go to rock creek park and
practice you really cannot it's like a
felony go to a national forest
go to national port start chopping down
trees i think that's frowned on bad
yeah that property you're looking at has
so many trees on it that we're we'd have
to pay people to take them
definitely we should coordinate them i'm
probably looking in the same area as you
are
middle of nowhere yep building
appalachian domes and you know dumb
housing super cheap
self-sustainable teach people how to
just you know
if someone can get this dude kanye he
builds come help us kanye
do you know about earth houses dude yeah
that's where you build them kind of
earth ship maybe yes where you build it
underground kind of in the side of a
that's your jam right there and then use
recovered glass bottles and stick it in
the wall to make like but you can finish
it up looking beaut
beautiful like beautiful i've seen
finished products
beautiful because they're kind of like
don't yeah i've studied those and
reported on them back in the day oh
sweet i've seen like first-rate
high-end finishes can't see any of the
tires in any of the bottles anything
everything looks beautiful and perfect
beautiful you fill up
tires with dirt yeah and then they end
up making like brick uh the guy said
that tires are the most abundant
resource on the planet
i believe tires yeah yeah wow wow you
know normally we would do super chats we
don't have anything to do let's
check twitter if you want to send me 500
super chat to my uh twitter mention
please go right ahead apple pen have you
been checking twitter luke
oh yes i've been checking all the news
that's breaking anything on the house
floor
uh everything's happening i mean it's
just absolutely
crazy in and we stole someone right now
i'm watching a meme
of spock playing four different chess
matches
and it says the united states attempting
a right-wing coup d'etat in latin
america
and then next to it is a baby playing
checkers saying the united states
attempting a right-wing coup on itself
so that's the meme that i'm currently on
right now which i think
should spark some interesting is it a
right is it a right-wing coup or is it
something that will bolster the security
apparatus and mass surveillance
potato potato i think we see what's
going to be happening if you want to
look
you know a lot of people always say ki
bono who benefits
i think that's something that we have to
keep an eye on in the long term of
things we do have some
some breaking news though the first
ladies chief of staff and former white
house press secretary resigns over the
violent protests from cnn
stephanie grisham and press secretary uh
let's see former white house
communications director and press
secretary and chief of staff for the
first lady
melania trump submitted her resignation
wednesday afternoon effective
immediately
in the wake of the violent protest the
white house they say uh quote has been
an honor to serve the country and the
white in the white house i'm very proud
to have been here
the first ladies did not uh respond and
then they go on and talk about just uh
what happened so we're getting some
resignations now i got a i got a
question by
son of a a be at that's the thing he
says what do you think the american
populist movement should do from here
that's what he asked me to through my
twitter account
luke we are changed specifically for
questions for us right now
what do you guys think i mean we have to
develop the bench
that's something we need new young
leaders across the board there needs to
be somebody coming up from behind
i did see eric and donald jr and
kimberly and everybody giving speeches
today
i don't know that that's the right
long-term strategy i think today was
just
decimated yeah so where where is the
bench
where is the where's the depth are there
any other young leaders is
who's the future that's that's a
question i'd like to rally
around an idea rather than a person
personally like um
i think that we could build an internet
bill of rights which is kind of what
we're doing at mines
with um the terms of service because
everything's getting so digital and
we're interacting so much online that
like a rights-based
future internet future could be
something that or it's
this is the boring stuff that will only
get like mediocre
retweets
yeah mine's bill of rights mine is
just radical self-independence yeah we
got another read we got another comment
by matt schauer who says bring back
your puppy of course captain ron says
this is a spicy one my veteran brothers
and sisters are not looking for a war or
a fight we are looking to protect our
homeland
tell ian to not to talk about our
mindset when he was never even
served or understand you know i've
studied i i
i got your back on this one man i've
never served in the military i've
studied and i've listened to a lot of
like returning vietnam veterans talk
about
their time in the jungle and a lot of
people facing combat i've listened to a
lot of their stories
um and i know that there is like we're
talking about the nightcrawler thing
like
there's a phenomena in reality where you
become trained to
live what you do and so i know that no
one wants to create
destruction in the united states but
there is no boogeyman
so we sometimes we just got to accept
that yep
at bad habit podcast says will trump
reveal anything classified to the public
in two weeks
no he won't be there no yeah because
they're talking about invoking the 25th
now but
more importantly trump has been didn't
he order several people to
release it they just don't do it that's
what that's what happened before
i mean the entire administration not
entirely largely been impotent in many
ways
fumbling around not making it and
stymied stymied and thwarted
from the inside i talked to a couple of
trump staffers
i had amanda milis on the show and i
asked her specifically how many
true like maga folks are in the white
house or nearby
and she's like a handful in the whole
freaking administration
and my other guys in the white house
tell me the same thing it's just
there's a handful just a small group of
people fighting
the whole time against mcmasters and
fighting the whole time against a bolt
in a deep state and everybody
that he's never had the he's never had
because he didn't build it
let's just put it squarely on him who
are like
we're just not gonna tell you that we're
not actually pulling people out of the
middle
right we're just not gonna tell you even
though you're the commander-in-chief
that's fine that's normal
right another question by at aspiring
rebel predictions for the next
14 days anyone want to take this one
i don't think the 25th amendment thing
happens i don't think impeachment
happens i think that everything calms
down
and then we have the inauguration and
then that's it and then who knows what
happens after that i really don't think
i don't i don't i don't agree we're not
saying what do you think is gonna happen
between now and then i don't think it's
gonna be nothing
i don't think it's gonna be calm i think
it's gonna be
uh hysterics and theatrics theatrics
sure theatrics are a given well
everyone's already quitting
yeah people are people starting to
resign uh objections are being dropped
joe biden will be president there's not
going to be a path
there's that's it it's over it's over
for trump but uh
trump but it's not so much about even
trump it's about what trump supporters
and especially people who are there in
dc
we might um i don't know if we'll see it
immediately though in the next 14 days
but i imagine there's gonna be a lot of
arrests
a lot of these people who are like live
streaming themselves breaking into
pelosi's office and using the phone and
laughing about it unfortunately i think
that should happen
be arrested baked in alaska people that
are like carrying statues out of the
capitol building after vandalizing
carrying the podium and smiling it's
like
auntie wears masks you know i feel like
um this viking guy that went and stood
up
in the or there was somebody in like all
gold standing up it reminds me of
camacho from idiocracy and i think he's
a viking guy i think
the media is trying to spin it to make
these people look like the idiots
from idiocracy so that they did go in
with a guy in a viking suit like
i am now the commander-in-chief weird
you know i mean if you went into the
capitol building picked up property and
took a picture of it and put it on the
internet
you are one of the imbeciles yes and you
should be put in jail i'm sorry to say
100 percent yeah that's 100 percent
smiling
on camera filming themselves stealing it
stealing things out of the out of the
capital trump could issue a pardon
he could pardon everybody he's not gonna
that guy's burning his bridges right
now every step he takes i'm so mixed i
am so mixed about today look i
understand why people are upset
i see it i see critical race theory i
see all of our institutions captured and
failing
i see our institutions making us sick
they're making us
fat they're making us stupid they're
putting us in debt they're creating
slaves to the system it's happening the
institutions want you dead
or not dead they want you barely alive
sick fat
and in debt and working at a slave job
for the rest of your entire life the
institutions have failed
i understand the politicians have failed
us every i understand why they're upset
and i feel the urge to do something man
remember when they were tearing down
statues like around june or july
i was on vacation i was in virginia
beach and i saw the the statues coming
down i just
wanted to explode i was able to get my
car and drive to dc and do something
i felt i understand the urge i
understand what happened today what do
you
think
every everything you said save the
tearing down statues you know being sick
being you know uh in debt go live out in
the middle of nowhere and survive on
your own
don't be reliant on the system uh
consume less use less grow more
there are answers right freedom there
are there are answers but it's a long
it's a long
push but we also have to know depending
on who the attorney general
is it depends if someone will actually
face the
the true ramifications for their crimes
so we also have to understand we're at a
political phase where right now
if your attorney general believes in the
same politics as you
you could you can get away with crimes
and people have gotten away with crime
that means in what 15 days or whatever
the
whoever is going to be coming in joe
biden called it an insurrection yeah
and he is going to you know they say
throw the book at you now he's going to
throw the whole like library at people
yeah it's going to be these people who
were in this building who came in
joe biden called it an insurrection yeah
so uh what penalty will they face
so just be so just so people know we're
reading comments people were asked
to send in the comments to lydia to ian
to jack
uh to me i don't know if you guys want
to send out your uh twitter handle
that'd be like
murphy live guys ian crossland yep i'm
collecting them
at we are at luke we are change
yeah yeah so i was noticing a trend in
the question and the basic question is
everyone i think is pretty shocked and
everyone's like
where do we go from here i don't know i
have no idea like where does the mega
crab that's literally what i was going
to read by comment by ash
below who says i'm a small business
owner in wisconsin
i just wanted freedom what hope do we
have now
we gotta think outside the box on this
this system is
very corrupt this this left and right
paradigm
is flawed
gently were you gonna say tim i hope
that these people didn't think
their hope was going to be a ragtag
bunch of trump supporters
in the capitol you're not going to be
able to vote someone in the fixes this
system is built to keep us in debt
it's uh we're under the thumb of a
global monopoly right now and the united
states has been
hijacked by a mined parasite that is the
federal reserve that's
using our military to maintain its its
strength around the world and so we need
a better system i think cryptocurrency
is a great one
so if you want to protect your future
finances you might want to consider
divesting or
diversifying out of the u.s dollar and
holding other types of currencies
and i think like you were saying
sustainability at a local level i'm
continuously urging my parents to put
solar panels on their houses
um because the cost of electricity could
be 700 a month all of a sudden well i
said per
i said personal radical responsibility
not sustainability i agree
i agree with what you're saying and then
in independence as well and i've been
working on this with guys in the liminal
order as well
we talk about traditional homesteading
like being able to go to the land and
make it
make it work for you we now need to
think also about info homesteading
there's there's more info than there's
land there's more data out there
there is gold in the info and data hills
you have to figure out you have to learn
how to draw that gold out of the
information landscape it's a separate
way it's a whole different universe a
way of being self-sufficient there's
self-sufficient with your land and with
your your energy and with your food
they're self-sufficient with mining the
information space that's out there
and if you can combine those two
together you no longer want to be quote
off the grid
you want to be off the grids you want
off of and on the grids you want to be
on and that's what i'm looking for
that's what i'm aiming for that duality
off the bad grids on the good grids with
a community and a network of my
choice or trump supporters can all pool
their money by an
island and create maga country yeah
i'll be right there they are i'm down
for building an island that'd be great a
friend of mine
builds islands out of recovered plastic
his name is richard sova
and um out off the coast of mexico and
he floats around on these solar powered
islands well the islands have solar
panels on them
he says that they can actually float and
fly because you create heat over the
island because of the trees that he
plants
so you get all this recovered plastic
put in burlap sacks then you put a layer
of dirt then another
bunch of bags of plastic another layer
of dirt and then you plant trees
the roots bind it all together and then
you float it around
and because of the heat that produces
above apparently you could create some
sort of lift
i don't know about that that's that's
crazy richard
lifting an island that's what he says
a lot of libertarians like seasteading
but i don't think that's what you're
describing
you have another comment by
neversummer160 who says my super chat i
promise i'll buy one
next time you're uh you're live if you
read this
deleting my twitter basically the only
reason i kept it was for trump
would love to see how their traffic
drops once they can
on the 21st love you guys keep up the
great work before trump twitter was was
collapsing
it was collapsing the stock was going
down user base was in massive decline
twitter changed their their metrics for
reporting to the like to shareholders
and investors
they said we used to go by like daily
users now they go by monthly
because it like made it look bigger but
going by daily showed the decline they
were in
and then trump came along and started
tweeting a whole bunch of crazy and
everybody started flocking to twitter
now trump suspended from uh twitter and
facebook
why has he not gone to minds or parlor
yet i don't go to mines don
do it now because he posts he could be
posting everything right now on any of
these platforms a week after
biden gets sworn in or within a week
trump's gonna just
he's not gonna be able to control
himself he's gonna tweet something
twitter's gonna ban his account
permanently
why because you know what you know you
know what uh new york i think it was a
new york mag had this article
where they wrote that the scenario they
imagine is that the inauguration happens
trump is flying to mar-a-lago when he
lands a bunch of black suvs pull up to
the plane
fbi agents get out and then you know
they're like
trump needed to come with us for
questioning and then in fact they were
arresting him
on federal indictment or whatever now i
don't think the federal government would
do that
but i think the states might i think new
york might because they they're they're
of currently ramping up a criminal probe
into the trump organization so they're
going after him but they wouldn't be
able to get him if he was in florida
they probably still would they still can
yeah this question is for jack and
someone says
the person is at ingus michael says jack
you said that it hindered the vote on
the floor but they were going to do this
anyway
that is why they did this i was there i
did not go in but i think they were
going to ignore us anyway
there's a lot of this is in that
question i'm assuming what they
he meant was that there were going to be
no dissenting votes
yeah well not the sending votes but i
think the process was done before twice
in american history and both failed to
do anything
or change anything sure so what did they
fail to change other than make
everything worse
yeah it just made it worse it went from
worse to worser
yeah that's great i've got one okay hey
lydia a question for the show this is
from rob the butcher
i find it very interesting that the
people in power praise destruction and
violence when it is not near them but
when
once it is done near them they call it
the most despicable thing to be done in
the history of
their country of course that's not
really a question it's more of an
observation yes 100
correct not in my backyard yeah right
exactly
there you go i got more uh lit drummer
boy says 1776 was over
less just saying yeah but that was like
we mentioned a hundred
several hundred years ago it was a
different world back then fewer people
we need a technological revolution now
i think i think it's in process uh if if
people
were using bitcoin more and and trading
uh different ways getting basically
getting away from the establishment
infrastructure
yeah using different ways to store value
being reliant on yourself
you're so right about minds dude i mean
this is like embedded in what i am i've
been doing it for a decade
well what what trump creating minds just
using a free software social network
that doesn't track you
i like mine i'm on mines i use it i like
it quite a bit it's a very useful tech
this is this is one thing i think you
know trump supporters can do especially
but
most of them are on parlor i guess is
use different networks decentralize
and uh start your own thing man start
building your own
you gotta build your own thing go out
and we need go find some land in the
middle of nowhere and you can get it
it's it's not that expensive in the
middle of nowhere we it's gotta be real
there's a reason for food yeah well
we suffer from a crisis of masculinity
in america and some of the traits of
masculine energy are to build and create
and protect and provide
engage those sense of your masculine
energy man
build create protect provide you can't
protect if you're in the city and they
can turn off your water
if you decide to have thanksgiving right
this was that was one of the things that
really got me
was just you know seeing what happened
in california when they did i had a
party
remember we talked about this yeah yeah
he was a rich guy anyway yeah i know but
still the thought was there and then
they
turned off the freaking utilities to his
house and they just made more videos
laughed about it
right you know it's easy when you're
rich to do that i'm thinking about
regular people i'm thinking about not
when i got when i got doxed and then my
city got burned
i got attacked by antifa a number of
times in the streets i got shot in the
throat once this summer
i felt like i didn't have anywhere to
really retreat shot in the throat yeah i
got shot in the throat by the cops on
may 27th may 28th with what
with one of those rubber bullets yeah
yeah well not a bullet not okay
i mean i would have been the only person
no no i got a rubber bullet right
through the beard in my
in my bandana right through the beard
how dare they i know
and that was like on the first night
where everything popped off for the
first time
but i didn't have a place to retreat to
like okay i've retreated to my
city home you know where i'm still as
vulnerable where there's still people
all around me where i still am
completely dependent on other people for
everything
i needed a place where i can retreat and
actually be safe and sovereign
yeah yeah at freedomring13 says what are
your thoughts on peaceful secession
no such thing no such thing does not
exist
why not well because whoever's in charge
of the
leading the government and the
constitution has sworn an oath to uphold
the constitution
and his historical precedent shows that
if states deceive from the union you
attack them evade them you kill them
salt their fields take their women ruin
their whole life until they say okay
okay okay we won't leave
yeah that's that's a historical
precedent
the war of northern aggression as they
call it a lot of comments
and i and i have to be honest here is
people saying what do we do next and a
lot of them are like but they use
violence so so those
that's the main sentiment so they have
the high ground that's that's the
metaphor that the media will protect
them
yeah the pundits will approve of it and
it's wrong to do it
and like i said if you they're looking
uphill seeing people pointing their
weapons down so they think i'm gonna
point my weapons down it's like yeah
well you're firing into the ground dude
regarding that what do we do next what
do you want to be the outcome
that's a question that you should ask
yourself and then the answer
should be okay peace is vague though
because if you nuclear
well freedom's also vague like regarding
peace if you
if you nuclear melt the entire earth
there will be peace
and calmness although there will be no
humans and if um freedom could be uh
you're out in the middle of the woods
starving
yeah with with no clothes on but you're
free to do whatever you want exactly
so we've what do you want to be the
outcome i got it
all trump supporters move to california
become residents
and then vote for the session succession
and then leave
get it like scuttling the ship and then
i'm kidding it'll be great well they
have an open ballot system where you
could put
certain issues on the ballot and then
people could vote on it on popular
demand so
sasha doesn't as a joke because it would
require two-thirds of the states to
approve it would be an amendment to the
constitution
so one thing people are asking about
that i don't think we've touched on
tonight is whether antifa was involved
yes
i wanted to talk about that i don't
think yeah we didn't talk about it
what do you think jack here's what i
think i think that antifa
has been waiting for this day for a year
they wanted to do that 70 day siege or
whatever of the white house
that fell through but all those people
from portland in seattle and across
country they came here
like they're here they travel across the
country they're in dc right and they've
been
training and planning and festering and
whatever
for months now and we also saw
throughout the summer that they changed
their tactics based on changes
of tactics by the police and the
government and so there was a dance
there was an iteration they changed what
they were doing they changed the point
of conflict they changed their
they changed their tactics i saw them at
the last event
they were in their own little private
pen counter protesting
right by the capitol it was funny sub
gorka walked right up from behind them
into their little like death pit and it
was funny scene because
i'm a big guy by the way i'm 6'4 250.
seb gorka is like
i'm like i'm looking up at that guy that
guy is massive and he was like
it was awesome uh but uh they were they
were clearly there they've always
counter demonstrated
they weren't there today they weren't
there where were they haven't
weren't they saying that they were
dressed up as maga people no there was a
uh
there were people on facebook i saw
auntie for people posting the other day
don't go let the fascists fight
themselves that was a meme that was
going around
so that was that's how i posted the
other day that's the thing about antiqua
you can just put on a maga hat
and go insane so women don't think about
antifa you could put on a hoodie and
you're right yeah you can dress like
anything it doesn't matter it's not like
an
organization it's right just an idea
it's it was the joke that uh all the
proud boys were actually antifa
pretending to be proud boys and all the
anti-farmer actually proud boys pretend
to be anti-fun because they're both
trying to make each other look bad
i mean that's basically it that's
basically they they're just
you know it's it's it's mutual combat
between those two groups and i say hey
let him have it i believe in mutual
combat if you consent to it let's do it
in some places it's legal yeah it would
probably solve uh some of our bigger
problems if we allow the little uh brush
fryers to take place every once in a
while
uh control controlled violence is okay
we have dueling
and then you know it was interesting i
was reading about why dueling ended and
it was because the younger generation
thought it was crazy that people were
killing each other over honor
so it stopped well the next generation
came in and that's crazy
yeah and like the duel with uh what was
it uh aaron burr and alexander hamilton
apparently hamilton didn't actually take
the duel seriously
and thought it was like one of those
duels where okay we show up
you miss we preserved our honor and we
leave but burr was like i hate this guy
bang yeah yeah so there's like different
stories like hamilton like purposefully
purposefully
missed thinking he was being a gentleman
and then he got hit in the gut or
whatever
i wonder if that's true or if he
actually just missed yeah those are his
followers
maybe history is written by the winners
so i don't have parlor on my phone
otherwise i would check this myself
but there is a rumor that i'm seeing on
twitter that president trump is actually
on parlor
which is very interesting to me tim do
you have parlor on your phone i don't
oh let's find out because i went to
google it and i can't really find like a
topical article about it
i only see you know newsweek crapping
all over parlor and business insider
talking about how it's all a bunch of
nonsense over there
and pro-trump riots and stuff so i would
be really curious if trump is actually
on parlor because that could be a
defining moment for them
hopefully a movement towards here's one
from
vice president-elect harris paint uh
does tim cast want to be
like political mr beast what does that
mean i don't know
i don't know much about mr beast we give
out donations to small businesses that'd
be so fun
you'd be like dave portnoy we can do it
in the vlog yeah it'd be fun okay so
don't find small businesses
a solid maybe if that's what mr beast
does he gives donations to small
he does videos where he's like i
secretly left a thousand dollars for
this waitress let's film her reaction
and the lady tim is like that yeah he
already is like that just slip money
into people's hands and pockets
and then someone else mentioned the
unity party which i'm not convinced
about the unity party i just love the
idea of a new fresh party we talked
about there was just jack i think maybe
last time or a couple times ago yeah
jack what are your thoughts on the unity
party at this point
uh is that uh weinstein yeah yeah yeah i
think that they had a noble idea
uh wasn't the right time uh didn't get
put into practice and they picked the
wrong people and a number of things
but i do i do like his idea i mean i
talked to brett on the phone about it
he even asked me who i thought they
should nominate for president and a
person i suggested
he declined uh but uh you know
is it is it going to be effective i
don't know i think i think more of a
hostile takeover of an existing party is
probably the way to go
uh there's a there's a long road to hope
i'm not saying it hasn't happened in the
past
we've seen viable third parties in the
past we've seen bible third third-party
candidates even in my lifetime
although maybe not in some of your
lifetimes you younger folks
ross perot was a real thing he helped uh
clinton get elected with neri what
forty percent of the votes huge big
years
yeah the biggest yeah so so do you think
that what happened today was them
trying to attempt a hostile takeover no
no i think it was some angry people
angry people who felt let down
and felt like this was them taking the
last stand that they could to protect
themselves their family
the future of the republic all the all
the things that
that have a hint of truth but but
also are overblown and used to
manipulate people and give them
hopes that something crazy was going to
happen when nothing crazy was ever going
to happen
i feel like people might have been let
down you know at the end of the speech
because there was no big revelation and
he basically was like
come on mikey do the right thing yeah
except he kept saying this weird thing
he kept saying
it's it's courageous to do the right
thing he goes well except
actually being courageous it's more
creative sometimes to do nothing
yeah i don't i didn't he said it like
three different times
it was it a veiled threat i don't know
it was like
it was just such a strange statement i
didn't really understand
people to stand down i didn't i can't
find anything on parliament yeah i was i
wasn't convinced and then melissa just
asks are you all going to start your own
site
we all need to get off from out from
under the boot of youtube and the answer
to that is yes
that is something we are working on
right now it's gonna be super cool and
it's gonna go hand in hand with the vlog
which i'm very excited about i mean i i
think it's critically important people
set up their own databases and
alternatives
i set one up for we are change.org i
have my own email list no matter what
happens
independence yeah yeah you have to you
have to be as independent as you can
nowadays you can't rely on anyone
because
it's only a matter of time i mean the us
president right now is blocked
on twitter and facebook he can't send
out any messages to the general public
through social media
wow that's that's that has implications
that that's huge
and uh you know there's there's a lot of
different questions
and uh a lot of spicy ones that uh
i don't even have notifications that are
exactly why youtube disabled chat for
probably yeah do you um when with your
we are change
database are you through aws with amazon
or i don't use amazon service no i don't
use amazon i try to stay far away
as far as you can away from it you
maintain like a
a database on site or do you have
someone maintaining like a local i have
a really good
web developer dave cahill he's been
doing an incredible job for me and he
does everything he sets up the servers
he's
uh he's just an amazing human being
that's been one of my good friends that
has been personally setting it up all
for me to
run independently of any possible
systems i'll take this opportunity to
say considering that
super chats and chats were disabled if
you want to support the show you can go
to you can go to
timcast.com forward slash donate if you
so choose and it would be great
greatly appreciated normally super chats
you know we read them and it helps
support the show but uh
a bit too spicy today i suppose so
that's not the one
social currency tonight unless you want
to jump in with something
and you can you can actually send tim
bitcoin i believe you have a bitcoin
address on there of course followers i
got all that yeah
i do and we're this is timcast.com is
going to be changing to
a unique site and we're gonna have it's
gonna be the site for the podcast and
then members will get access to
exclusive stuff and things like that
so we're going that direction we also
have you know sponsors now for the show
ever every so often um which is great
which is you know basically because of
things like this
right uh we did we we read uh two
sponsor spots this week already
and the good news is something like this
happens where the super chats get
disabled that's why
i'm like you know we got to be careful
we got to probably take on some sponsors
also it's not that easy to get them so
i'm really grateful that we did but we
got to
make sure we find ways to survive after
you know social media becomes get
creative worse than it is i guess
you know i'll tell you one thing i
wonder what would be happening on
twitter
if they didn't ban many of the most
prominent
trump supporting personalities what
would they have been saying on twitter
while this was going down
because i saw some stuff from some high
profile people that i was like i can't
believe they tweeted that i don't know
what who just encouragement to go do
what they did today while it was going
down encouragement
interesting right and i was like i can
only imagine participation
yeah they were some of them were there
right some of them found themselves
in the office of the speaker on her
phone
i don't know how that doesn't land you
in jail bro
yeah and trump's going to be out of
office there's not going to be any
pardons for that
no and if they put in a new aeg which
they will oh for sure
it's not cuomo they announced i think
who was going to be already oh yeah it
was someone terrible
oh and before i just have one more point
to make um i'm noticing a trend where
people
are being combative about whether or not
this was a bad idea
and you guys i don't know what you know
about the patriot act but this is going
to be a 50 times worse response
you guys have no idea right
we just got a full democrat democrats
just won georgia guys we lost
everything and this this is a wonderful
nomination
and all the institutions and and with
that the first point of order is going
to be the insurrection and addressing it
and some sweeping national security
order and truth and reconciliation
commissions and that will exacerbate the
problem and that will be the democrats
gloating while they spray
a flamethrower on the fire while they
claim to be fighting against it and
that's going to make many of the people
who are angry right now even angrier and
that's the problem
and what do you do what what happened
today was
in my opinion poorly thought if not not
thought at all
and hurt everybody and gives the
democrats
uh an excuse to signal to their base
which they will do
and they're doing now cory bush saying
it's treason then and that's going to
make more people feel
anxious scared civil war trending
and then the democrats will respond with
some you know
truth and reconciliation yeah then
that's going to make people go nuts
robus pierre during the french
revolution they created the
committee of public safety is what they
called it and that's the committee that
had 15 000 people beheaded executed that
were like political enemies of the
revolution
it's coming maybe more metaphorical the
beheadings but they're definitely coming
yeah
yeah we're we're we're we're well past
that era but something will happen
there's actually
it's going to be unpersonal it's going
to be like we're banning
you from financial institutions like
they've already been doing
um yeah is it called the truth and
reconciliation
that's a committee right now yeah the
democrats have been calling for truth
and reconciliation commissions and
military tribunals
and banning people from uh doing you
know basic things like we already see
something
people from congress cnbc is now
reporting that the flight attendant
union
wants pro-trump rioters barred from
flights
so we're going to see similar actions we
already saw paypal ban a bunch of
individuals we already saw banks
ban other individuals because of their
political opinion i think it's only fair
that that's going to happen here
and one of the questions was what are
you going to do when they ban you from
from buying land because of your
political opinion that was one of the
comments that
people are sending me uh specifically
here people are gonna go insane it's
gotta be a human rights issue then at
this point if the government's gonna
maintain a monopoly on finance which
they really want to
then it's gotta be a human right we have
to defend our human rights as americans
to finance so i have a good question a
really interesting question from justin
graf
who says is it possible that today's
self-destructive self-destruction of
trumpism may actually be a good thing
for national populism in the long run
boogeyman is totally destroyed and the
woke establishment train is too loud and
fast to stop i don't think that they
will think that this boogeyman is
totally destroyed they're just going to
keep spinning it out forever whatever
happens
but i don't know will it be good for it
for populism in the long run
no i don't think so i think now the
what support trump had is gone and trump
is an absolute absolutely an imperfect
avatar for it but now
it's the baby out with the bathwater you
know
i don't like nationalism in general
nationalism and populism is what led to
hitler what led to mussolini what led to
donald trump and not that he's in
america so dangerous
um the federalists and wanting to form a
nation and manifest destiny and all that
stuff it was states rights at first
the united states federalists yeah but
the reason we
we formed as a bunch of states working
together it wasn't like and the united
states was formed
i mean abraham lincoln he was a national
uh
was a national unionist he was he
suspended
yeah it was crazy stuff but i permitted
the war of northern aggression so
but i think people generally agree that
abraham lincoln was one of our greatest
presidents i like the guy from what i
know about him
i think there's a lot of division on
that but he wasn't really a populist he
ran against three
other there were four presidents running
or people running for president
when he got elected and um he was kind
of a nobody
but the least worst he won with like 33
percent of the vote i'll tell you what
look
i am all for one world government
unified currency and human beings so
long as we have
our freedoms our rights our constitution
the problem is the people who are
proposing this kind of stuff
don't want that they want to take away
your speech they don't take away your
rights
when trump went to that meeting on hate
speech in in europe and they all signed
signed this paper on like pledging to
ban hate speech trump said i can't do it
it's like it's a violation of our
country's constitution and they were
like
all these news reports come up saying oh
hiram trump refuses to pledge to a fight
hate speech it's like he can't
speak so the problem is look if china
ends up taking over
then you get to live in a society where
they'll weld your doors shut and let you
die in your home of
dehydration because they don't want to
get sick in the united states we have a
constitution protecting individual
liberties
if the world was was founded upon this
con a similar constitution that
guaranteed rights
i got no problem with that it's fine
that would be good yeah the problem is
people in this country
in the world don't all agree with each
other and some people have really crazy
fundamentalist views and will throw you
off a building if you
do things they don't like yeah and so
how do you so so what ends up happening
is we say
we have a nation we have borders so the
people who want to do us harm
can't do that we have to make sure we
have security so what
what do you do maybe once we're unified
around common human experience
and i don't know how long that will take
we can be like yeah we have one world
where we all agree but we don't
we have disparate communities and
cultures that very many of them hate
each other
and we'll fight each other it reminds me
of this you guys you guys know the far
side
gary larson yes yeah i love that there's
one where there's a terrarium
and there's two aliens looking in and
there's a grizzly bear
roaring and like about to hit a human
and he goes you put incompatible species
in the same
container like there there are certain
ideas
that oppose each other and will lead to
disastrous consequences
until humans agree on fundamental
principles and rights
what do you do but have nations but i'll
tell you you can have nations
and the rights of america can be
respected and still have international
agreements in trade
and and some kind of you know united
nations or committees
that negotiate to keep things and keep
the peace and stuff like that
that makes sense it makes sense that we
have different countries with different
rules the problem is what happens when
china has concentration camps
and no one does anything about no dude
or when you're homosexual and you go to
that country and
you get your hands chopped off or stuff
like that you're sounding very alexander
dugan right now with multi-polar
nationalist identities in the world
you know he sees a space in the world
for this type of civilization that type
of civilization this one
you know eurasian and american and
persian and and the chinese
and he thinks that they should be
allowed to be themselves multi-polar
nationalism i mean i don't i don't know
uh
if if i think one thing one way or the
other i'm just saying it's what it is
right now
yeah right right now you've got people
who live in europe and they love
the lockdowns they love the the blocking
of speech
they like it there are people in sweden
who cheered when
uh journalists published the private
information of citizens who had bad
opinions
they love that in america we we have
people who like that too
we as a country on our founding
principles we don't like that kind of
stuff
so it's it's a challenge i mean right
now you can go
uh well not everybody but you can live
in different places
you know if you have the means or the
resources if you want to live in a
democratic uh
uh social a social democracy like the
the nordic countries and then have your
speech curtailed because you have no
problem conforming to the opinions of
others
then you go you can go right there and
do it you know it's weird to me
that so many people want to uh well i
don't know
you know i guess the i guess just people
want what people want and then how we
how we
develop and advance and and move forward
is yet to be seen
i thought if we have one language as a
human species that
that we would tend towards a global
community and
and that like the good ideas will rise
to the top twitter
we all speak english in the united
states and i don't know china
and and they'll even cut those people
off from the internet so that they can't
hear us
talking because when they find out what
the america is
about people people in america speak
english but they have different
definitions for many different words
anywhere there's no problem like you
can't move to germany and just
get along you got to learn german i mean
you kind of can't because they speak
english
right yeah if they didn't speak english
it would be terrifying you'd be
surprised you can go basically anywhere
and they speak english
which is good i think that's the step
towards unifying it has it made us more
peaceful
definitely it used to be just chaos i
mean world war
ii was was was horrific world war one
was they called it the great war because
so many how many hundreds of million
hundred million people died yeah
um yeah it was like a language barrier
ultimately the germans and the french
couldn't they didn't know how they
played soccer together they didn't speak
one
one day on christmas they actually all
like spoke multiple languages
and they still do in europe they do yeah
and and like the swiss i think speak
three languages yeah german french and
uh
swedish swiss swiss not swedish swiss
yeah
yeah multiple languages well i think
we're all sort of winding down getting
tired
of just exhausting conversation what do
you think of jack
i think tomorrow is going to be scary
just
i mean what do you mean why where do we
go how scary just look at what happened
today
the tensions are higher than they've
ever been the escalation is more
dramatic
you look it was one thing that people
stormed the building that was crazy but
to then have
politicians being like treason expulsion
they were like
let's throw tinder onto this fake the
social media censorship it's worse than
it's ever been
the the potter kick is going off so i
think it's like a slow explosion right
now
well there was a really funny tweet
where they said well that pop up that
that popped off very slowly over four
years
yeah right yeah it happens slow time
you know and then every day and i keep
saying this
sure maybe tomorrow we wake up and
everyone realizes well that was crazy
let's all calm down
do you really think that's what's going
to happen i don't think so yeah trump
will be gone everything
well anyway my friends thanks for
hanging out we went we went we went a
bit over and i'm getting pretty tired i
think everyone's getting a little tired
so
make sure you follow me on twitter
instagram and parlor at
timcast you can check out my other
youtube channels youtube.com
timcast and youtube.comcastnews and you
can also support the show by going to
timcast.com
donate we had our super chats shut off
today um by youtube
for answered questions for a lot of
reasons but we try to answer some
questions through twitter and stuff like
that but if you want to support the show
normally super chats are a big
contributor you can do that at
timcast.com
donate we are live monday through friday
at 8pm so of course we will be back
tomorrow and uh we'll see how things go
but uh jack you have your own uh
channels and socials
indeed jack murphy live go to the
youtube channel hit sub we got another
interview we did brian long comedy uh on
monday
probably the funniest man in america
right now that was excellent interviews
amazing
we got christopher ruffo coming up
tomorrow at uh 12 p.m
eastern standard so please hit sub on
jack murphy live also follow me on
twitter
jack murphy live and if you're
interested in the things i've been
talking about masculinity sovereignty
brotherhood independence self-sustaining
come check out the liminal order that's
liminal hyphen order dot com
luke apparently you have a website talk
about very similar things so it's good
to have you on here if you want to
support my voluntary efforts here you
can
on we are change.org forward slash
donate if you want to check out and buy
some of the shirts that i'm wearing on
the show
i can it's very timely i've been i've
been selling this one for a few years
now
you can on we are change.org forward
slash shirts
so yeah go check that out thanks uh hey
you can follow me ian crossland on
youtube facebook twitter and minds but
if you really want to support the show
and you didn't get a chance to super
chat i'm wearing a shirt right now
that's actually a picture of tim
we know if it's in frame lydia yeah yeah
there we go
we have we have two shirts coming up
soon i am a gorilla yes yeah and then we
have one that says i am a gorilla love
yourself
so if you want to support the show you
couldn't do a super chat you can buy a
t-shirt you can actually
they're right below the youtube video we
have a list of our shirts that we're
selling and
this is my particular favorite so
everybody hooked me up with one i love
it
got it gotta put that on the drinking
game set
yeah you can follow me at sourpatchlids
on twitter if you want to i post a lot
of random things some people say i'm a
great follower other people don't but i
have a lot of them
join me the best lyds pretty good all
right everybody
get a good night's sleep everyone take
it you calm down a little bit maybe play
some uh um you know some little mobile
game on your phone
yeah some tetris how about that and uh
wake up tomorrow refreshed feeling great
maybe get some exercise eat right
and clear your mind we'll be back
tomorrow at 8 pm live thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all then
thank you
you